i'm not chrissy drip drop anymore you're
chrissy five drinks in oh yeah [ __ ]
tommy segways chrissy down the middle
i'm chrissy grayson
chrissy [ __ ] hips chrissy pilots i'm
old for nine
if i go over ten great dude on chrissy's
strikeouts it doesn't matter
well welcome welcome to your mom's house
you know people say to me they say
christine
your website is fantastic did you build
that yourself and i say of course i did
silly goose i used squarespace
i have used squarespace for years
why i like their templates they're clean
concise fantastic for mobile most people
are going to look at your website
on their phone and it has the perfect uh
layouts they're
just fantastic their customer service is
unbeatable
uh there's never any plug-ins you know
you ever go to your website and they're
like you need to do a plug-in you're
like what's a plug-in i have no idea
customer service uh is fantastic free
and secure hosting
built-in search engine optimization and
analytics that help you grow in
real time and you can customize the look
feel the settings of products with just
a few clicks super easy so what you're
going to do try it out go to
squarespace.com for a free trial
when you're ready to launch use the
offer code mom to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain
squarespace this episode of your mom's
house is brought to you by
saatva go to saatva saatva.com
the [ __ ] to start with 225
off any purchase of your choice they
have it all and we've had it all
we've had a lot excuse me we've had a
saatva
luxury firm mattress we've had a memory
foam lumen leaf mattress and now
we have the all-new sole layer mattress
which is so comfortable
and it vibrates you to sleep if you want
it to you can set a zero gravity setting
so you feel like you're floating in
space you can have it sit up
when you watch tv or you want to take a
bite of something in bed
you know having just one of those days
or it leans all the way back down for
you it's fantastic
i love this thing you should treat
yourself right and get one
too amazing customer service mattress
takeaway service they do it all
saatva saatva.com
slash the [ __ ] for 225
off the mattress of your choice welcome
to the greatest podcast you could ever
find anywhere on the interwebs
it's your mom's house i'm tom she's
christina
we have christine christine i'm todd we
have a great
show planned for you hey y'all we do
have a great show y'all today and you
know what they say
great shows when rubbing your armpits
together and they stink that's what they
say
it sounds like that old texas saying we
were hey
well we were we were down in texas
you know y'all hey y'all
well
[Laughter]
you know what they say texas is good for
two things
queers and stairs and i don't see no
horns coming out of your head
okay yeah it was great i
had a lot of barbecue i loved me some
barbecue yeah
it was really good food really nice
people
really fun but we're going to have to
start saying y'all now which is going to
be difficult
if we go there again if we go there
again there's so many other places to
live
y'all you know where i want to check out
where y'all where
wyoming i like why home and team big
open land just be up there with kanye
and
friends is that where he goes i didn't
know that yeah he's got a big old ranch
up there
goes up there when he's having an
episode breakdown
yeah sounds perfect and then other
people come visit him and tell him he's
fine
yeah you know what i really liked about
austin though
is they're not hysteria about covid
i like that they're like i don't wear no
[ __ ] mask and then
we're shaking hands and i was like whoa
handshakes out of the gate
they basically they're like like they go
like are you stupid or
no okay okay like that and then they
shake your hand yeah it's pretty funny
you're not a queer they they have the
the masks they all have like masks like
on their chin they're like do you want
me to do it
i will if you want me to i don't want to
do it and you're like okay they were
like yeah it was always
i guess don't do it and they're like
okay that's what i thought yeah it was
always a dance and there was one
particular and we got kova tested
yeah negs got back yeah super neg
uh sorry that sounded like a different
word i didn't mean that to sound that
way
but that swab was aggressive let me tell
you that guy
swabbed my mind yeah he was like you got
it was terrible but we're negative so
super negative
and uh hiv negative yeah there was one
guy we
were talking to and momston and if i'm
negative you're negative because
we were [ __ ] partners that's right
there was one guy who was so close to us
who was talking and he was
larger heavier gentlemen and he was
sweating
oh my god profusiously sweating he was
profusely
sweating he's talking at us and i was
like whoa bro
you just slow your roll homie he was he
was re and he was so
fired up so far yeah and he was he was
so worked up that he was like
he was working himself out of breath and
then he was making me anxious
yeah because of how he was just like
yeah
okay okay okay okay calm down he
couldn't slow it down he was just
super pumped he was excited he was a fan
he was excited i know he was nice
very nice guy a lot of nice people there
well lots of nice people tom
well you know what they say
you know what they say if you [ __ ] your
dad on a friday
you're going to have a hell of a weekend
welcome to texas y'all so
if your [ __ ] stinks you put a whoa
hammer inside of your coop i don't know
all right i can't think of anything
um there's so much to do
we have great clips we have a great
guest
we have great songs we have great emails
so many exciting
it's gonna be a banger and real quick to
mention
uh unbelievable feedback and i'm so
happy
specifically specifically that so many
people
were blown away as they should be at how
funny ian bagg is
oh my love we've known it for years
you've heard us talk if you've listened
to this show a long time
there's nobody like him and uh i got so
many messages
of people being like this guy is so
[ __ ] he really is
he really is go go stream the albums go
watch the specials
and when you can go get a ticket because
it's really something to see him live
he's a joy he's such a breath of fresh
air
i really enjoy having him on we got to
have him back soon i know
so funny uh go
to dot com tom segura there's a new
thick boy nation hoodie
there's a new ymh zip up hoodie and
there is a new jean hoodie two new jeans
oh mg
all new for hoodie season which is here
now
[Music]
all right opening the show you ready to
go i'm ready let's do it ready to go
so i just seen this girl's ass in the
other aisle about four aisles over now
she had a
big ass but it wasn't the
good big ass see there is uh several
different variations
of having a big ass there's a good big
ass there
is an okay big ass and there is a bad
big ass
don't bring anyone wait for the
breakdown
welcome welcome to your mom's house
with
welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
oh yeah yeah
this seems like a pretty cool guy he
does seem like a
official cool guy here's a deal man
though is that because i don't really
have a great ass
i don't really look at asses on other
people i've kind of just
like written myself out of the aspect
you have a great answer i don't it's
just it's a shelf it's not an ass i've
got tits
the lord blessed me with tits but no ass
and that's fine i'm fine with it
but do you know what i think he'll be
the judge no okay yeah
you're right don't you dare inject
yourself into this conversation
you don't know anything this guy knows
everything and
this is my favorite thing about a cool
guy okay is not just
having this information floating around
in your head but making a video and
sharing it with you
that's the important thing yeah you know
a bad big ass will be
something where an ass is the shape of
spongebob squarepants it's kind of just
like a big
square it just looks sloppy and look
messy
it's like the small dick of having a big
ass
the small dick of having a big ass never
have there been truer words spoken this
guy is phenomenal
i'm gonna put it like this uh her big
weird square
pants ass over there i'm not into it i'm
sure it was real
it was just kind of sloppy it's the kind
of big ass that when you come home from
working on hard days
work 12 hours 14 hours breaking your
back you come home and you
look at your girlfriend and your wife's
ass you're just like
no yeah
now me personally i would rather have
a woman with no ass than a big fake ass
if you have naturally wide hips if
you're naturally thick and you go to the
doctor and you get a fake ass
and it matches your body it's all well
into the good
but there is a lot of women on social
media platforms
who do all kinds of stuff and modeling
and they got these disgusting fake asses
and it's really just it's getting to the
point now
where i'm just i want to vomit
my my fake ass that i hate the worst i
hate when chicks
that have absolutely no muscle tone in
their thighs or their legs they get
these big fake asses and yet their legs
don't match isn't there anything
it's really disgusting i'm actually
getting really tired of it yeah very
tired of it yeah if you'll excuse me i
gotta go
oh thank you there's a cool guy
uh this guy first of all thank you for
making this thank you
great explanation and he makes a lot of
good points i'm glad that he took the
time out of his day
to update us on these ads well and you
know what's really great about this cool
guy is that he was so
moved by his own thoughts i mean he's
shopping he's in the shoe
that's what i mean he had to stop at
target or walmart i got to talk to you
about these fake asses
right now there's a lady two aisles over
who's just living her life but she makes
me want to puke
i just felt the need i'm compelled to
tell you guys about it yeah it's pretty
cool cool guy hey
you're a pretty cool guy here how soon
into dating him
do you realize what a cool guy he is
pretty soon
i think it's like for it's on the
approach here's the thing now he's a
high level
cool guy where like he's the kind of guy
where you could think that he's not that
cool
and then you would find out he would he
would
he would um show his colors and he'd be
like
oh but i don't think it would be that
deep but i mean like if there's a
spokesman
that they're looking for to represent
the cool guys he's the guy oh yeah yeah
he could definitely
well because he's pretty well put
together in terms of most of the cool
guys we encounter
and way way more articulate his
vocabulary way more
that's what i'm saying like we're
talking about a press secretary for the
cool guys
i think we found him i think that
they're like
who can stand up for us and he's like i
got you guys
well tom it's funny you mentioned this
because matt
s uh has submitted this and i think it's
just
fantastic uh he made he's an
attorney and he's as a licensed attorney
in the state of
florida likely home of many cool
cool guy club members i've taken it upon
myself to draft on a pro bono basis the
attached ymh cool guy
application form 23.95 oh my god here it
is
this is unbelievable he writes i believe
it covers all the key elements of a
proper cool guy this is
amazing oh my god
department of [ __ ] rtd
23.95 form cool guy application
are they a meth user homeless black guy
who likes to [ __ ]
tick tock account holder a [ __ ] jew
retired double agent
oh my god i didn't know that if you've
checked
retired double agent enter the number of
baby rapers you've stamped
oh my god
look at this too you put your name your
last name your parole officer's first
and last name
[Laughter]
your self-assigned nickname and or title
uh-huh
if homeless check applicable sleeping
location
your babies wherever you get free food
free oh my god and here's an applicant's
personal information we're looking at
teeth color number of teeth missing
direction of right eye
direction of left eye intensity of stare
number of strokes to climax last item
placed in
ass last location of public urination
last location of public sex act that's
good
and then there's a yes and no boxes here
we go ceiling fans yes or no
unflattering camera angle yes or no yes
applicant is nude
yes someone else is nude yes [ __ ]
lighting
check inserting items into bodily
orifices
violent sexual theme that's good use of
the n-word
very very good yep that's what you need
poly people slash nre friendly
oh this is great too catchphrase and
then women should
you just finish the sentence women
should
shut the [ __ ] up clean unprompted
an actual attorney in the state of
florida and this is why you go to law
school
this is exactly why this is brilliant
sir my favorite is direction
which way do your eyes go
there's some it's amazing this is and it
really looks like a government form
can we put this on the site somewhere so
people can download and fill it up fill
it out
it's pretty amazing jesus christ
i mean that must have taken at least two
billable hours
this guy lost money doing this
that's really fantastic god bless you
matt
you got another one yeah there's there's
a lot of mommy mail redos
let's bring up remember the infamous
short video from last
yeah a week okay so regarding the video
yeah let's refresh everybody
okay regarding the video uh
i can i can confirm to you that he's
speaking romanian
oh wow now i thought ukrainian judging
by gypsy
yeah judging by the accent he's very
likely from transylvania
okay okay word by word he's saying
oh [ __ ] your mother's god i have shat
myself
that sounds a hundred percent like my
tribe being uh my neighboring tribe
[ __ ] your mother's god being a very
popular phrase around these parts that
basically means for [ __ ] sake
i feel very honored for our people to
appear on your highly esteemed show
and we romanians send you all the best
and hope your country doesn't burn down
to the ground because
that would mean that the russians will
probably [ __ ] us up
[ __ ] us in the ass in the future you got
it claudio thank you so much for
submitting this
very important yes
um um okay do you want to see
so you remember the really cool guy with
the um
like the obama flight flag thing
and the denver airport i've been
thinking about him a lot
i mean he's denver airport he's out of
control of this guy right
welcome to revelation unraveled this
program is a continuation of my series
on the denver international airport this
guy
is unbelievable international and below
obama's logo we have two stripes and
three stripes
which look much more like streaks of
blood
that's unbelievable i mean the fact that
and
so what i didn't realize man uh we've
we've um
we've seen him before uh he he made a
really cool
2016 election song
which the cool thing is you can
repurpose it because there's a new
election coming up
and there's a reminder here's that song
oh thank god
okay
[Music]
he made this
vote for the donald trump is the man
let's put our nation into his hands
mike pence and donald make a great team
they'll make our nation the greatest
it's been
actually i mean it's a great song team
in bean that's a slant run
it's just it's cool to know that he's on
that side
the right side if i was like this is who
likes the same guy as me cool
he's got it together so um
well what's fantastic is he was doing a
live stream
and some of the mommies got in there
so we got him to say some ymh references
you ready
yeah let's see to the revolution digital
market income
fed smoker
let's see i pray our dear leader picks
the honorable rpc to replace rbg
let's see our pc
i'm not sure our rpc that's robert paul
yesterday to replace were appointed by
ruth bader forgotten what their initials
all were
yeah so yeah he's consid he's he was
told that robert paul champagne
uh should replace um justice ruth vader
ginsburg pittsburgh
which would be an amazing thing to see
rpc
on the supreme court yeah hearing
arguments and and writing his opinions
yeah
i'm just thinking that is the people i
think you think guy
she won't have sex in the streets it
should be fine
[Laughter]
so funny that they actually got him to
say it fed
smoker
look at his shrine behind him boy oh boy
he is really into the lord
it's an encouraging sign of sanity
it's got an altar it's pretty great boy
oh boy
um yeah well that is normal you want to
read another one you have another one
yeah people were really upset about
rbg's death my goodness yeah
people were really crying on instagram
oh this is interesting what up chomos i
was watching episode 570 christina you
turned down the heat and turned up the
ac and then put
a hoodie and sweatpants on and got into
bed thinking you were gonna cuddle with
your husband
if tom runs hot you don't need to bundle
up
get naked and use your cold body to cool
him off while he warms you up
and while you're at it eat his ass do
your wifely duty and make him come
harder than rpc quit being a scared
little [ __ ]
and take some pride in satisfying your
husband please realize it's not about
you it's about making him come so hard
is
okay i'm gonna throw up the point being
stuart thank you is uh
he's stewart stewart i appreciate your
love get this guy a free t-shirt okay
all right
oh my gosh oh man
you want me to do that well
but i understand what he's saying is
that it's silly because you you i was
i forced you to cuddle with me two days
ago your body was so on
fire you keep saying it are a meteor but
you're playing
like every night now you'll come over
you put your hand on me and you're like
jesus christ you're so hot
right and i do it i'll take stewart's
advice here because i am being stupid
if i'm wearing clothing that is not a
good idea because you're a
woman a [ __ ] stupid woman yeah and i
i should clean up unprompted
but that that makes a lot of sense
stewart so i'm going to take that and
consider it into consideration
thank you and by the way i like that's
kind of one of those things where
you know we could probably get the uh
the cool cuddles going
and then maybe sexy times come and then
we both are like hey
that was real nice we laid naked in bed
and yeah
i'll warm you up and you'll cool me down
we'll be affected
but here's the deal man is that i give
you like we do affection
and then you're immediately like well
that's [ __ ] now yeah i'm a guy
i'm warmed up right you married a guy
right you want to [ __ ]
you know scissor with some chick who's
like let's read a book then marry a
chick
i'm a guy is affection too much to ask
i'm a man
i know you're a man i'm a man can you
cuddle for a minute and then we [ __ ]
give me five minutes of cuddling at
least because
women are stupid when you're done then
you bagak and then you're like off to
get the sandwich downstairs and then
there i
am right i am a human male
okay let's talk about it human mail the
other day when we were in the momston
hotel we were staying at
you walked down the hallway we were
finished we finished this
great dinner where we gorged ourselves
like animals
you walked in front of me and you go oh
i got a fart and then i
walked in the wake of your fart and i'm
like you don't even respect me as a
woman
anymore like you are purposely now
farting and then i walk
into the fart cloud
you used to have some kind of respect
for me so
maybe if you treated me more like a lady
i would
you know what i'm saying with the cuddle
you would be required to to make daddy
come on
and i want to just give it i want to
give a plug i think that the restaurant
that made me fart was
called red ash it was so good it was so
amazing they're
bread alone jesus christ [ __ ] the points
that are
good i ate to the point
of it hurting my stomach i filled it up
with so much food
oh my god okay here's another one this
is in the drops folder
sagura so ready yourself hey jeans i was
moved by tom's beautiful transition
story from tom to tammy as a fellow
bearded guy
and tennis player i can relate to the
story and don't feel my mediocre tennis
talent celebrated enough because i'm a
man
that being said i have another rare
talent and that is transforming tom to
tammy by the magic of drawing
this is beat me lean fan from denmark
oh that is amazing yeah this is
you know what i love i'm telling you i
could [ __ ] up some amateur
women's tennis players i've been playing
a lot
he mastered your thighs and your little
hiney there and
your fart you're i guess you're farting
your skirt up i think i'm just moving
no it looks like a fart wind and then
your pony is
ridiculous your ponytail that's so good
yeah perfect this is what i want to do
and i think i should be accepted by the
tennis community
as one of the upcoming rising stars
in female women's tennis i think i'm
immediately
on the tour immediately well like here's
the deal
is that in today's culture they can't
refuse you
i was there like i identify i am a woman
here i am guys
i was playing uh yet no sunday i gotta
take him and um
there was a guy who's one of like the
really good players
um that i see regularly at the courts
playing with a woman
and she was unbelievable she would
she was destroying i mean she was legit
like 5-0
maybe i don't know higher than that but
she was
she was really good good yeah yeah there
are a lot of superior female tennis
players we're not saying that
but i'm saying that we put you on the
women's team and you could destroy the
bottom
players really really really and get all
kind of sponsorship i think it would be
really fun
i think you should ruin your life and
try this
i think you hate me i don't hate you i
love you for you to say that to ruin my
life
i'm your biggest fan i'm happy for you
too i must say because
foosball is back as much as i hate it
when you watch the football game i was
really happy
that you were watching the game and
enjoying yourself and you and your dad
call each other and you guys talk about
the stupid game
it's cool it's nice it's really nice to
see you enjoy that and i think it's good
for morale for this country
yeah i think it's um might be ending
soon
with the news of i don't know titans
last week have
players and personnel who knows how this
is going to go because if
people start testing positive and that's
the thing about football is the teams
are so big
you know i mean like in the nba playoffs
they had them all move and live in a
bubble
right so you like they really control
the bubble in the nfl
you have 53 roster players you have
a practice squad with another i don't
know 20 some players or something
uh personnel wise you know there's a
hundred personnel
on each team it's so many so many people
just on one team and there's 32 teams
and like
each of these people have you know uh
friends family staff like associated
with their lives
yeah i think i don't know it could go
sideways well but
it was really fun to watch some games it
was fun to watch you watch the games
because i know how much joy it brings
yeah and your dad and stuff but
we talk he's like do you see that guy
he calls you what a catch he really
caught that ball
[ __ ] yeah and i hear your conversations
on speakerphone i'm like this is the
dumbest conversation
look how dumb this guy has missed this
block [ __ ]
[Laughter]
your mother could have blocked that guy
and then your dad loves to make fun of
my
ignorance of the game as well as your
mom's ignorance ask her
ask christina ask her what happens on a
safety
like i don't know no he's like of course
when's the last time you got rewarded
for brushing your teeth
with quips new smart electric toothbrush
good habits can earn you
great perks like free products gift
cards and
more you've probably heard us talk about
quip a million times
but this is something brand new that
rewards you and your mouth
the quip smart brush connects to the
quip
app with bluetooth and you can track how
well you brush you get tips and coaching
to improve your habits
you earn points for daily brushing and
bonus points for completing
uh challenges like you get into a good
tooth brushing streak
you can redeem this stuff for rewards
come on now free products
it's pretty cool and also we love the
children's toothbrush
you know when the kids watch us use our
quips they they want to use them right
yeah
juju and they want to use everything
let's grab them right out of my hand so
now there's a kiddo one which is you
know got the size down features small
brush head for small mouths it is
awesome so start getting rewards for
brushing your teeth today and go to get
quip dot com slash mom right now to get
your first refill free
that's your first refill free at quipped
dot com slash
mom spelled g-e-t-q-u-i-p
dot com slash mom quip better oral
health made simple
and rewarding we all know 2020 is a
little nuts but that doesn't mean you
should disregard
your nuts no matter what size or shape
they are in fact
manscaped is on a mission to take care
of your manhood
with their below the waist grooming and
hygiene products and great news they
just released their products
in the uk canada and australia
rejoice you can have nice smelling
trimmed
balls bollocks and whatever else you
call it
in those countries um yeah it's you know
it's always a challenge to keep your
nuts
fresh trim smooth and manscape does it
all they just released the crop care kit
which is a formulation bundle to give
you a
plus balls it is the ultimate male
hygiene
hack they do great products great
technology lawnmower 3.0 trimmer offers
a replaceable ceramic blade with
advanced skin safe technology
so you don't have a pool of blood
underneath you every time you trim your
balls
get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
mom add some swag to your saggy bag
you want to see a funny video well i was
just going to get into oh yeah this
subject
yeah yes so the other so you were
watching what was the team the green bay
packers yeah they were playing the
saints
and it was a phenomenal game and then
you were like oh
oh dude
could you do a poll and ask people
if they actually usually call the
packers the fudge packers
and the 49ers the 69ers and then
well because i think that in in secret
like in
everybody secretly at home when you see
the
packers the green bay packers
immediately i i assume
everybody goes oh yeah the fudge packers
yeah or
the 49ers oh it's the 69ers like that to
me is where my brain would normally
put that poll out there over 20 000
people voted
very important yeah and look what was
that 55 percent
or is that what it says yeah say yeah of
course and of course
they call the 49ers the 69ers and the
green bay packers the fudge backers
but 44 said no i'm lame what's going on
with you people
i mean to me that's a no-brainer right
when you hear those words you want to
make them juvenile
yeah well this got us going and i think
we should really start pushing for
laws to change well we need to get
people
to reach out to the
organizations that are running the
presidential debates and see if we can
get
one of the two candidates to commit
will you force the nfl to change the
name of the green bay packers to the
fudge packers
right and the san francisco 49ers to the
69ers we need to bombard the candidates
team trump and team biden and say like
what side of history do you want to be
on
you changed the washington redskins to
the team from washington yeah
you know you're like oh that's offensive
i agree it was the right move
when are we gonna you know embrace the
69 or san francisco it's just
all gays and then yeah the packers
everyone knows that they're fudge
packers well i think
the point is is that there it should be
more inclusive i mean that's right
the packers what does that even mean but
i know what a fudge packer is and let's
make that
that section of look you're 100 right
anybody disagrees with a [ __ ] idiot
so hopefully we'll get um get a lot of
people involved with this
change.org change.org we need we need to
get the petitions signed and if we get
enough
signatures you know that could end up on
someone's desk they could actually do
something today's world there's so much
[ __ ] going on
that if we actually got people to sign
petitions
to call this this year we need to get it
signed and then like on the like just
just have like a press conference where
they're asking jerry jones like the
owner of the cowboys do you think they
should change the 49ers the 69ers he's
like what
do you think the fudge packers should be
the name of the package he's like i
don't know nothing about that but i'll
look into it
[Music]
right into the back look at this guy
look where's my phone
oh there it is i got my phone
just going to hop off and the driver is
just like
keeps driving away damn that's what's
happening
overseas and if you let the dems take
all right so communist countries
that is wild that guy acted like nothing
happened that was crazy
geez he flipped right into the bed
homeboy went down
didn't even scream there's audio there's
like he's just so chill
what asian country is this happening
his face went into the bed like the back
of that he hit it with his whole face
that's crazy barefoot he's got [ __ ]
flip-flops on too did you see the one i
don't think i sent it to you
on instagram i could probably text this
to you
and you could put on the screen this is
insane
this guy um
yep here it is here i'm gonna send this
to you
this is so crazy should i email it to
you
yeah this is um
[Music]
this guy is these are these guys are in
mexico i don't even want to like
describe it
because it's just better it's just
better to bring it up
this video it's so crazy that i'm not
going to describe i'm just going to wait
for you to bring it up
um um
tell me what you if you find this or not
i just saw i was
i i was just scrolling and i think i i
landed on this and i
i could not believe it but it's really
this dude's like behavior
as this is happening that stands out
almost more than what is being done
okay watch sound
yeah start from the beginning turn the
sound up and go go big screen if you can
here we go watch
he's like what happened look at that
dude he's like what
oh my god dude he must be loaded right
oh yeah he's still completely hammered
yeah but he's just he didn't even flinch
damn he didn't flinch at all he's
following
close range shot off the top of this
and then somebody underneath they wrote
welcome to mexico
because that is that is in mexico so if
you're listening
a guy's at a backyard party puts a
bottle of
liquor on his head and then from a few
feet away a guy with a pistol
shoots it off of his head i mean the
dude next to him is all of us right the
guy who's like what the [ __ ]
oh my god so that's the right reaction
yeah exactly another guy's like what
happened
you worried about the uh cops being
called here
don't worry about it jesus christ i know
i know
it's so in look at him he's like what
what yeah
let's let's see he closes his eyes oh
close
so he has some indication that stump
something's going to happen he's like
yeah i'm fleeting man we got to do that
here
yeah that's a great idea we'll just
rehearse
and then we'll go to the other guys
after that i think the dot first and
just knit it up the dial first and the
dive last and
just rehearse a bunch with him
full clip all right we got one bottle
12 more here we go are you a good shot
i'm decent i'm all right i've been going
i've been going to that place you saw me
in that video
well that's close range you know that's
that's pretty easy right
i mean uh yeah that's pretty easy
target's big could [ __ ] up and the cool
thing is if you [ __ ] up
you just uh kill somebody
immediately well what if we got him to
sign a release
uh just that his family doesn't sue us
and stuff yeah
oh that would be cool would you sign
that release yeah i think you should i
don't know
i think i'd have to have a lawyer look
over here that's that's the right answer
i don't know but i'm still part of the
team okay
we'll get into it we'll talk about it
we'll talk just think about it we'll
talk about it and by the way you're
gonna do it think about it um so
oh really excited to plug yeah the
cockroach josh potter has a new
podcast it's called roach motel with
josh power this is a long time coming
we've been working on this a long time
the episode the first episode went up a
week ago
the second episode is out now
it's going to come out every tuesday at
6 a.m please
subscribe and review on itunes and
stitcher and everywhere you can listen
audio-wise it's on our youtube channel
we are
so happy i'll also point out because
some people have asked about it
if you're noticing that shows are coming
out
early in the morning now 6 a.m that's on
purpose we um
you know we were thinking about it and
talking about it was like well these
should be available in the morning so if
you're trying to
get ready and go to work or you're
driving or whatever commuting
you can listen in the morning we had a
noon schedule for a long time but now
six a.m pacific nine eastern
you will get uh new episodes released of
all shows listen to it on your
drive-in yeah you're driving you're
never doing it you're riding your bike
yeah yeah you're going for a walk
oh and also congratulations you know um
a lot of people told us to take it easy
on ed asner coming so hard
but i also wanted to congratulate hendog
because he was smart enough to put his
banger on itunes
so um i posted that that uh that song
with his he has like artwork to so much
but then i just saw
so many people reposting that like
they're listening there so
i think that's really smart you have to
think too big hit song you know make it
available
make it available bros put it up on
itunes you should do it man i agree
also big big news for us uh two bears
one cave
live is october 15th ooh
that'll be fun 5 p.m pacific
that's 8 eastern that's thursday october
15th the tickets are at ymh
virtual dot very exciting place
for those who are wondering about ymh
live it does return in november
so we will have another ymh live in
november
if you missed episode one or episode two
of ymh live
you can go to my site tomseguro.com and
click on the video
rentals tab and you can watch episode
one or episode two or both
and as we build uh this live content
out and these shows they will be there
available for you to rent
if you so choose it's exciting also we
have dr drew after dark
that tom and i and potter guest on yes
and where my mom's at to i know a lot of
dudes listen to this show but if you
want to get your lady friends on board
with the ymh clan
maybe you can get her to listen to where
my mom's at and segway her into your
dark world of your mom's house there you
go a lot of times
bros are like my lady doesn't like your
[ __ ] it's too crazy
get her onto where my mom's at that's a
good way to get in and
eventually she'll be with us in no time
yeah doing nasty [ __ ] over here
[Laughter]
so we were watching the foosball game
and then a commercial
came on where this guy was mowing his
own lawn yeah
and i turned to you in bed and i go is
is that real do people really
mow their lawns because growing up here
in l.a
right nadav like you're a native an la
native you just don't see people mowing
their own lawns
yeah la people don't do that yeah that's
really interesting because i think
that's very cultural
all my my first uh 14 years were all
midwest
cities yeah and suburbs and stuff and
we always always mode our lawn but the
same thing
exists here in in florida
which is basically nobody does that
there either
i think it's because maybe because
they're so hot it's so hot and it's all
year long you have to do it whereas in
the midwest you have those snowy months
like maybe you're not tending your lawn
yeah but i
really found it like very um
you know soothing like it's a very
satisfying
thing i bet i mean but i see so the
thing is though is that it looks so hard
it looks like you're pushing that heavy
thing
because it's so sweaty it looks like the
most unpleasant [ __ ]
it's not that it's not like it's not
weights
you know you're not like oh [ __ ] i can't
move this thing like it just goes
it goes i don't see how though it's so
heavy
and horrible i like that you don't lift
it up as you're mowing it
you just you just hold and it goes and
it just chops up the grass for you
it still looks like the most horrible
thing it's hot i mean
it's work because you're out in the
blazing heat right i mean in florida
it was 100 degrees plus 100 humidity
yeah miserable
like that's that's real work but um i
love when we lived in
in milwaukee in the suburbs of milwaukee
we got we went from the
push mower to the sitting riding mower
now that's that's [ __ ]
that's good i feel like that's cheating
though because like
you're just sitting yeah and he agrees
with me you're just sitting there
driving on grass it's you're not pushing
hard you're not sweating
dude you can make patterns in the grass
what did you draw like big dicks big
dicks usually yeah
what the [ __ ] is this like what's a big
dick let everybody know who lives here
man
i'm great no it's fun man wouldn't that
be great to pay your gardener to do that
for you put a big dick in balls on your
front lawn
so do you want a big
big finger there in the grass i think
see yeah
how fast do you think you're going to do
one balls to be big two or smaller balls
how do you want to i can make them big
if you want but i think
the league should stand up they should
have their balls a little smaller
i'm like yeah that's a good point thanks
rafi wouldn't that be rad though
like imagine if we bought like this
palatial estate
and then you had your gardener always
always all the landscaping here is
sexual themed okay
so when people pull up they know what's
happening
okay and that'll be so [ __ ] funny
dude it's gonna take extra time to make
you want these bushes to be tits and
over here we have
yeah yes and there's a big vag opening
jose how come there's no nipples on
these dudes
it takes a lot of practice to make the
nipples stand out
i think your gardening bill's a thousand
dollars a month because of all the time
it takes them to do it do it a lot
faster and save you money but you always
want dicks and tits and everything so
it takes a long time can you make the
pubic hair look softer rafi
yeah i have to go buy some special grass
and make it look like a pubic hair
everywhere
you know you guys are real sick people
you know
perverts yeah thanks i would like to do
that what if we bought a house in texas
and we had like a big front line big
dick yard it's all
dicks and balls i'm sure they'd be real
happy the cigarettes are here
hey y'all hey y'all
stick some balls everywhere we could um
have a fountain like a dick fountain
that spurts jizz
too that would be fun oh god that was
maybe just spurt water well you know
what i mean
like people are filling it up every day
for us coming by and jerking off in our
fountains so we have real jizz
and we're like hey guys could you come
over and jerk off in our fountain
we want to seem authentic
so nasty oh man that would be super fun
yeah no so anyways it's not that bad to
mow your lawn
yeah i didn't know that and i it's one
of those well you're right that you get
a big break because i remember
you know and you stopped like let's say
in november or something
in the cold cold states and you're not
doing it november december january
february like
you you have like five months off yeah
so that's probably why
in the midwest it's a source of pride
like and and at dave pointed out we were
talking before like
you don't really own your house here
most people don't own so it's like why
would i take care of my rented
property or i lived in apartments
growing up too so like we didn't have a
lot we didn't have
lawn yeah so i guess i was really
shocked to see like
that commercial i'm like no uh it's not
a [ __ ] motherland what is the [ __ ]
[ __ ] is this
a lot of people know their line it's
lies
propaganda yeah not here bro okay
okay all right
well well
um dick and balls so you want to know
something funny
yeah bertrand he says a lot of words
wrong yeah
one of them he says wrong here we go
look what do you call it when a person
rubs your body
massage therapist massage you say
massage i say massage
that's so dumb massage massage your
whole your lips purse out
massage yeah yeah isn't that dumb and
you know who else says that
yeah another guy says massage massage
yeah how many drinks is bert drinking
right there there's
one massager well someone's never
watched two bears before
two three four five yeah oh yeah i live
two bears
you guys are always doing this [ __ ] for
the last 15 years
how dumb is that massage massage
we need to have a whole soundboard of
just him and his
dumb words that he says massage your
little hole
yeah that's not how you say it's massage
massage yeah he says nightmare nightmare
benefleck he says benafleck benefleck
yeah
silly it says all kinds of things
completely wrong
so silly yeah um that leanne really
likes him too
yeah she loves him yeah
um how do
you sent this yeah i haven't seen it but
i saw that why do i treat everybody like
[ __ ]
and why have i been so [ __ ]
successful over these 25 years
because it [ __ ] works and the reason
you're here you snowflake [ __ ]
is because nobody treated you like [ __ ]
tough love works
you [ __ ] weenies
he's kind of right um and pena right
there the best
always giving you the truth you [ __ ]
snowflakes
he calls them [ __ ] jesus
tough love works i'm the alpha male
father you never [ __ ] had
most of you should have never been born
you should have rolled down the inside
of your fat mama's leg
god
yeah tough love works guys it kind of
does i mean
you always hear these really successful
people
and they all have these horrible
nightmare stories of
childhood a lot of times nobody is like
well i had really supportive parents
and um everything was great and so i
decided to become
the ceo of [ __ ] amazon or whatever
or i created the internet it's never
dude it's always like
yeah yeah my dad beat the [ __ ] out of me
or it's always like that i know
i know it's adversity so but you see
like all those people there
and sitting in front of them they're all
like they want it they love it they want
that tough love
well i think well you know tom what they
say
well discipline no i do think i mean you
look at our kids they love boundaries
they love
they love discipline they want you to be
like no dude
you see it with little little kids they
you go don't touch that and they're like
you're gonna [ __ ] touch it right and
then they go what are you gonna do about
it get off that then they're like
they like it they do yeah i think
everybody naturally wants
um a little bit of you know a boundary
everybody needs it yeah for sure
um so where is this uh oh yeah
so this dude um you know our cool
the conspiracy guy fed smoker yeah
uh brings up fence marker we did another
we got a dive here on fed smoker yeah uh
well there's
more new but old you know you know you
don't realize it's all in the past on
the vaults
right but i'm saying what an opus of
work he's left i have no idea
it's so inspiring every time that i see
one of these in the folger i perk right
up i just
i can't wait to see what it is here we
go gosh oh you son of a [ __ ] is out
there thinking you gotta wear a jock
shirt
and [ __ ] to get some [ __ ] i just left
uh ontario
a couple days ago got a little bit of a
story and
got some [ __ ] [ __ ] notice i'm still
not wearing a [ __ ] shirt
yeah that's a good point so what uh what
herc's saying right there
is that you don't have to wear cool
clothes to get laid right oh that's the
you know that's
the message you know he's got so many
points of wisdom we need to start
putting them
down that you don't need to wear a shirt
to get laid no especially not like an
expensive shirt
no goodness no these [ __ ] clothes are
way
overrated for [ __ ] getting [ __ ] i'll
tell you that
yeah that's all i'll tell you
clothes are too overrated they're just
overrated man
who needs a [ __ ] preppy ass shirt or
do you get a shirt to get some [ __ ]
yeah yeah and also you know what's
what's really often overlooked
is what an incredible vehicle the ford
crown vic is for him
right to be able to drive i mean i'm
assuming
he was probably clocking a quarter
million miles a year in this thing
i know driving day and night and this
thing do you think he did maintenance
checkups on this
no no this thing just goes it would be
great if he could be the spokesperson
ford built forward tough
yeah well if he says i was in ontario is
he meaning ontario canada
uh yeah my my province birth town i
think so
and although that would suggest that he
has papers
which i think there might be a and it's
not ontario california
but no there's probably some other
ontario ontario's yeah okay well
yeah i don't think he's like got my
passport
yeah i don't think so and i definitely
don't think canada would be like come on
in
to fit smoker no let's check out this
background oh yeah
yeah yeah felon they don't let you in
they have a lot of uh jail time
well that's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
teeth what kind of ladies do you think
he's getting very cool ladies
very very refined i want to know who
he's romanced
if you were with fed smoker let us know
yeah ladies of the street probably yeah
ladies and gentlemen
she was good [ __ ] man really good
i drilled her for about two and a half
hours figure
and i got bored and got off and come
back to my room
two and a half hours
such a good summary of a story
i drilled her for like two and a half
hours and i got bored
got off and went to my room yeah okay
i know he sounds like fun time he's a
buckowski that's how bukowski would
write
and i mean i'm not a lady so you should
probably be the one to vote here
but in my experience if there's one
thing that
that most women like it's two and a half
hours of drilling
drilling well they're like yeah perfect
and the word drill that implies bang
bang
bang yeah yeah yeah just a prison
pounding yeah
as hard as he can go as long as he is
and really it's exciting as a woman when
you're like will he come
won't he come how long will this match
what's the amount of time this feels
good for i'm thinking 150 minutes
something like that you know two hours
plus is where to go
yeah getting drilled oh wait he does
have a check engine light on tom
oh that thing stays on do you think that
he's actually ever been like
gotta address this issue
[Laughter]
i wonder what my oil oil reading's like
right now
chevy the official car fed smoke
starter belt i don't know what's going
on with this thing no
drilled her for two and a half that's
not that's an exaggeration
for about two and a half hours i figure
that's that's gotta be an exaggeration
[ __ ]
bored okay does math give you math dick
like what does it do i mean it makes you
come and throw strokes probably really
hard
and ready to go but you [ __ ] but you
come in four strokes and it's
thick hot water that's just that's just
that one
one guy okay that was just one guy
she was good [ __ ] man yeah because
meth
is like the they can become so sensitive
yeah but that's not usually what people
say that's one dude most people say that
meth is like
that reckless drug of you're like let's
just [ __ ] all hours oh
it makes your dick go harder for a long
time yeah could you hit that mic more
what's going on with you today
you've done it like six times
i mean i mean i do it
it's a podcast are we on nbc i know
we're on a podcast
i know my coffee's cold okay
why don't you smoke some meth i wish i
had meth right now
you're like it's a podcast do what i
want okay all right
oh that dog is upset what what's wrong
no no no then just saying hitting the
mic is definitely not a good move
i'm just pointing it out what why are
you mad at me
because you're mean how does that mean
you fart and make me walk into it
is that mean you don't cut at all i
think you definitely could have been
meaner
i think i think you did it in the nicest
way that you knew how thank you
thank you all right i'll take it fine
okay so what is this saying about meth
here
can you make that bigger my dad eyes so
uh the results show that method and
sexual functions are not
the first usage is uh what is that
uncommon non-committant tom with the
increased duration of sex
an increase in the quality and quantity
of sexual pleasure a delighted orgasm of
feeling of more
control of the sex act these effects
gradually decrease
a decreased libido and various sexual
dysfunctions
such as erectile dysfunction premature
ejaculation and losing control during
the sex act will appear over time
wow i didn't know that that's really
well he's a long time method he's a long
time
user i'm surprised he can get his wiener
up or that he wants to be
it says that the the sexual function
goes down over time
yep so interesting there are differences
in the libido and sexual functions of
meth users
personal perceptions of one's sexual
function may be affected by cognitive
changes
resulting from the drug yeah dr drew is
always saying that there's this bummer
of brain deterioration that happens when
you're a regular meth user and that he's
seen
permanent yeah um cognitive like
dysfunction function yeah it happens
it's such a bummer because you want to
try it and you want to get into it but
to know that that's going to happen
i'll have to say and this is going to be
the official word from us
don't get into meth yeah yeah it's a
real
real sad day but our studies have shown
[Laughter]
that you shouldn't but i didn't realize
how much great art
that meth produces i mean in terms of
talks and
these videos i just didn't realize it
inspired people in so many ways
so many ways i mean and then it almost
makes you want to go did we just change
our position
on whether or not you should try it
because you just made a great point that
the art
and heart's kind of awesome i know i
don't i got this from an artist
can i yeah yeah what is that it's a math
artist
no oh no what is that smartest what's
the animal there is it a crocodile
what's it say
well it's two dinosaur bone marrow
pharaoh yeah that's kind of neat
matthew ryan is it haggard i forgot
about this that's really
cool um i'll tell you right now because
i
should yeah her get sorry hurricane
h-e-r-g-e-t
that's really cool where is he from
uh he lives in the los angeles area nice
yeah
nice very cool don't you wish you could
decide who lives or dies
yep they do you were saying that
why do you want to decide who lives or
dies because i look around and i'm like
in my head i'm always like we could lose
that one
right there we could use that one we
could lose that one we could lose that
one and then you know there are
there are people different who thought
that same way i know
and they've tried it some i might be
genetic matches
sharing a dna type you know what i'm
saying like my heritage is what i'm
saying
yeah what
they i mean are you talking about
genocide well i'm not saying
no i wasn't thinking in terms of
rounding people up according to
collective attributes uh i was thinking
in terms of the individual
for instance if i see a really you're
behind somebody
at the starbucks and ah i don't know
hemming and hawing dead you're gone
you don't agree with me yeah that's
pretty good that's true what about okay
what about the douchebags who ride their
[ __ ]
uh bicycles in the streets yeah it's
very dangerous here
that's that that's annoying and today
we're on the freeway
and it was pretty open and we were
behind a guy at one point doing 45
not for a moment like that was his
cruising speed
right gone you should be able to kill
death next
your life is meaningless to me you know
what i'm like upset that i didn't get
involved in
the riots really yeah what are you
feeling because i saw these like
storefront windows i'm like that's got
to be so satisfying to break those
windows
but and i know that people did that i'm
like you kind of want that one
that seems like fun but see i don't have
that destructive
impulse like that i want to clean up the
world
from the riff raff you want to destroy
the world you want to throw
a brick in the window i don't i don't
have that impulse yeah
i know what i've been doing lately i
didn't tell you this what following
people
no boy so following regular people or on
i just pick someone no no in real life i
pick someone
and i just follow them that's neat like
stop sometimes
walking around and sometimes i'll follow
them home and i see if i can
how long i can follow them without them
okay yeah that's illegal isn't it i
don't know
are they all women yep petite blonde
mm-hmm that's pretty cool
i uh i saw one the other day at the mall
and i was like i'm just gonna see if i
could follow her home so i watched her
get in her car i got
mine and then she stopped for groceries
i went in the grocery store
then she got out and she went to a
coffee place i followed her that and
then i followed her home and i waited
outside and i watched
you know what did you do then i just
watched her spouse arrived and i was
just like i know where you live and you
know
i just told myself i could do whatever i
want check you back later
do you ever make contact where you're
like can you help me lift this couch
no but now like i get i gave her i gave
her a name in my mind
you know oh what's her name that's
sheila
sheila yeah and and okay
and she lives in our neighborhood no
just live in our neighborhood
you go to other people's neighborhoods
well you know you're also a recognizable
person i have a mask on oh and a hat and
sunglasses
okay yeah and but you know what i'm
going to do next though i'm going to go
back to her place
i'm just listening to this i'm going to
go back to her place and leave her a
note
okay i i mean
it's kind of illegal how is it illegal
to say
hey i think you're real beautiful you're
gonna tell her
what are you gonna tell her i'm just
gonna tell her she forgot to get the
cucumbers when she was at the
grocery store because she picked a
couple up and put them down and i was
like
maybe i'll give you a reminder you know
it's a good time
[Laughter]
you know who else i think should die who
every time
we back out of our parking lot our
parking what's the word driveway
the garage i have to back up the way
that it works okay
and every [ __ ] time our thing
is on an incline so it's dangerous for
me to do so
and every time i bought back up and
there's an indignant
jogger just the jogging in place
passively aggressively looking at me
like you [ __ ] you're backing up
it's like yeah [ __ ] i'm backing up i'm
the one who can't see you
you know what i'm saying like maybe you
shouldn't give me such a nasty look why
don't you go across the street and jog
around me stupid [ __ ]
i agree with that i agree with that
because i also feel that way about
um like if you're driving and there's
a cyclist right oh boy and you can take
them all in and you
hate them you go to turn and the cyclist
is going straight right so you're going
to turn
cyclist is going straight and as you're
turning they go like
hey yeah but you can see that i'm coming
up on this term yes yeah so you can
actually you actually have a better
view of everything you can go like oh
well the guy driving the car
yeah is about to make sure i'll slow
down so he can make and then i'll just
keep going but
some of them go like no i'll accelerate
through it because i have the
right-of-way
even though i'm i know i'm in your blind
spot right that's
i know that you yes are missing it right
now because
i can put i can deduce from the rate of
speed and you're you're decreasing your
speed and that you're going to turn
and they just do that and those people
should be [ __ ] neutered
neutered and murdered and and strung up
in public and made an example of
and drawn and quartered too yeah but
here's the deal because that jogger does
know
and i know this [ __ ] who's jogging all
the time is she knows that she's in my
blind spot like you said
and i don't want to hit her of course
not and i obviously am the one who's at
a disadvantage
so be the bigger person even though you
might have the right of way
by the way if you tell me more specific
details about this person
i'll [ __ ] follow you home i can't
and i will wait out so i'll sit in your
yard you won't even know i was there
don't think i won't follow you around
all right make you nervous
think about it all night
i love that feeling knowing someone's
scared
what about anybody that makes a
speakerphone call oh god
in public yes right they should die
right yeah of course
yeah the [ __ ] hammer to the face yeah
yeah
so good man
i'm in a good mood now
great ah
here i haven't seen this this looks like
it'd be funny let's check it out
[Music]
holy [ __ ] man damn
what is he saying we're not sure it's a
foreign country
it is and what i just realized is the
guy walking by
i thought was concerned for the dude
that just fell but then i see he just
kind of stiff arms them back onto the
floor
so i think that guy was maybe saying
something mean to the old guy that was
that was putting him down but he was not
trying to help this dude
jeez
jesus
i mean that's a that's a oh
[Music]
no he he's there can we pet that dog
is that why jesus christ man so if
you're
listening there's a guy in a wheelchair
who rolls up
and shakes a ladder until it falls down
and the guy
falls with it like from pretty high up
man
and that guy walking by i think he's
just like hey don't don't
okay and then he's just done he's just
like don't escalate this to either one
that is a really crazy we don't know
where this is though huh
nah i thought it was maybe some sort of
latin country i don't know does that
sound familiar to you what he's yelling
no because i thought at first i was
thought it was i thought i was hearing
english
you know i thought he was saying
something andrew that's what i thought
you said
something like that that could be
melrose but i don't i can't
actually make out too sounding type of
word
maybe you're right i'm just not hearing
it well i mean maybe i'll try one more
time
oh it still sounds mostly english
i don't know why it sounds like english
to me
no it's too muffled for me i can't make
it out i don't know
wow that was a really inspiring clip
guys yeah
[Laughter]
um all right we're about to go take a
break do you want to watch this uh
one last thing here i'd love to um well
you sent it in
i make difficult decisions every day
but not about tampons i switched to
playtex
it's unbeatable protection only playtex
tampons have a double layer design
our [ __ ] itch they smell like fish
it's really cool
not about tampons i switched to playtex
they're comfortable and they get a
special plastic applicator
and i'll put these [ __ ] things they
have these huge warts that grow on them
that's really cool babe i love these old
tampon commercials it's so stupid
the audio slowed down so they're like my
tampons
yeah i keep trying new routines
but not with tampons playtex tampons and
playtex deodorant tampons
unbeatable protection 1982.
they smell like fish yeah
i love the pretense on these like i make
a lot of hard decisions but not about my
tampons like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
so much to consider out in the world but
not what i shove up inside of me
i know it's so bizarre what a promise
what a premise
um okay let's uh let's take a quick
break okay we'll be right back
i'd like to thank our sponsor whoop we
know a lot
about a lot we know 2020 has been a
tough year to say the least and we know
we want to live
healthier lifestyles but we don't know a
lot about ourselves
and how our behavior impacts us you can
get to know yourself
on a deeper level with whoop the fitness
tracker that provides personalized
insight
into your body's recovery strain and
sleep with actionable feedback in real
time
for me i love monitoring all the data i
think the
best thing i like the most of the woof
is that sleep coach you know sleep
is so important the longer you live the
more you realize that it's so
so important to get great sleep and take
care of yourself the sleep coach will
tell me
you have this is the sleep deficit
you've built up you need to get more
sleep to perform better go to bed
at this time it'll tell me go to bed by
11 15 to get up at this time
and you'll feel better tomorrow and i
follow it i really do
for our listeners woop is offering 15
off with the code
your mom at checkout go to woop
w-h-o-o-p dot com
enter your mom at checkout to save 15
percent
get to know yourself on a deeper level
unlock yourself
with woop gene you may have noticed that
i have been watching
doctor who on uk netflix
what how am i doing that you might ask
expressvpn it's wonderful expressvpn
lets you change your online location so
you can
control where you want sites to think
you're located
you just open the app you select a
location tap one button to connect
and refresh the page to access thousands
of new
shows and movies i mean you can choose
from almost a hundred different
countries how awesome is that you can
watch whatever you want
and there won't know tom they won't know
you're super you're you're a
hacker secret you can stream in hd no
problem no buffering or lag
it's compatible with all your devices
phones laptops media
media consoles sorry media consoles
smart tvs and more so you're going to go
to
expressvpn.com your mom to get an extra
three months of expressvpn for free
expressvpn.com
your mom super excited to be back here
with a very special guest
all the way from the great big apple new
york city
yes chrissy d history hyenas christa
stefano thank you very much for coming
thank you for having me guys very happy
that i appreciate it i'm covert free
coverage i believe i do have prostatitis
so i got an inflammation in my prostate
really
i just i think i do i just every what
you think you do
every day is a really specific thing to
say you know what's a nice thing though
every day because i had it once like two
years ago but it was one thousand
percent from chlamydia
but now which is nice i'm not chrissy
drip drop anymore
so but one remember who gave it to you
no i mean it's one of
i was a blur i was a full-blown sex
addict two years like not
you know two years ago you were yeah i
was like i don't drink i don't i don't
drink that much and i don't smoke i'm
fine but then i was just
you know just i mean dude there was
back-to-back nights
sex with like a woman who was the former
miss canada
oh wow and then one of my mom's friends
kate so it's like back to back
former miss canada 68 year old woman sex
addict
do you did you go to rehab for it no you
get therapy at all for it
yes therapy a lot of meditation a lot of
reading a lot of
thinking about you know like um like
narcissism
and entitlement and things like that
yeah that's fascinating getting deep
into that and now
and and so and so now i'm sitting here
with prostatitis and it's a different
feeling because i'm like i know it's not
from an std i haven't had sex with
anyone
but my girlfriend in you know whatever
it's it's been
i haven't seen her in three weeks so
it's like you know that's i mean i've
been
the thing i literally think i could have
like inflamed my prostate from jerking
off
yes i think so are you aggressively
doing it
i can't explain to you like why i've
been here for three weeks and it's been
unbelievable like i've been jerking off
to anything like everything
yeah i was jerking off to anderson
cooper yep two days ago
wow then this morning tucker carlson
yeah all you know they had an all
that's going on and i was just like and
i don't jerk off like this
i rub the base of my penis and i blow it
into my belly button
yeah it's a very strange way of
masturbating and i think that might so
you rub it against your belly
i kind of rub down and make like a
little vagina with my thumbs and i rub
the base and then i shoot it into my
body seriously i swear to god
i got to tell you something i mean with
that i mean i don't even know you that
well
yeah i would i would like to you to do
it to me yeah
and i would dude i absolutely would that
sounds like a really good technique
discover this technique i don't know i
just
i i think when i was a kid i just um you
know
i kind of i use because i used to take a
pillow i used to like masturbate on a
pillow i slept in the same
room as my mom until i was about 13 14
years old so i used to like you know
when she was sleeping
yeah quietly just take a pillow i used
to do that i started i used to hump the
mattress yes i was having orgasms before
i ejaculated oh me too
i was i was absolutely shooting blanks
and i was like like trying to explain to
my cousin
yeah brian i was like do you do that
thing cause i didn't know words for it i
was like
you know where like you you you like you
rub yourself a certain way and your body
shakes and it feels good he was like
what
yeah and i go you know what i mean like
and then you kind of sweat a little bit
yeah i don't know
what you're talking about well i mean
because i would do that so much i would
masturbate so much and just shoot blanks
that the first time i did get just a
little bit of jizz i lived in the same
house as my mom's sister and she used to
watch me
well while my mom was at work and i i
was like
doing it like rubbing the pillow hard
and then a little splooch came out and i
was young and
inexperienced i didn't know so i ran to
my aunt colleen i was like aunt colleen
something's coming out of my peepee and
she's like an old-school new york lady
smoking a cigarette she's like
christopher listen to me you're gonna
have to talk to your mother about that
i remember she was blowing the smoke
she's like i can't even deal with this
right now
and then i'll never forget she's like do
you want assault team cracker
and then uh and then ever since then
yeah so i just have a weird
relationship with sex that i had to
explore like i for very long i didn't
realize like i
absolutely fall in love with men but
have sex with women
yeah yeah because you mentioned anderson
cooper so you masturbate while watching
him
but i don't know that i was thinking
about him i was thinking about other
thoughts but it's just something
soothing
but you do fall in love with men have
sex with women now hold on
what do you mean you fall in love like
emotionally you're in love with a man
but physically you're into a woman is
that what you mean yeah i think like
i'm not gay right i don't have any even
really gay thoughts like i've never
thought about
having sex with a guy but i have
talked to men for a long time looked in
their eyes been fascinated by their
conversation yeah
and either went home and beat off or
went home and had sex with a woman
oh wow so i don't know if what that is
where that falls you think that that's
because
men are more interesting and smarter
okay
it could be no women are [ __ ] stupid
because women are [ __ ] dumb
no no
yeah i could no but hold on but are you
aroused but you're not aroused sexually
when you see
do you watch gay porn no i've never
watched gay porn never watched gay porn
or you never tried and
have you seen it can you bring up two
guys but [ __ ] let's just see
how it feels yes but this is fascinating
because you said you can have
you can you can hang out with a dude and
be so
fascinated and so in like be like this
guy was awesome
yeah but then you want to go and have
sex with a woman yes like maybe it's
just excitement
oh here we go or something yeah i don't
know yeah no see this is that a guy
having sex with a guy oh this is one of
these are women these are straight okay
gay yeah hold on i've never searched for
this but
gay porn yeah well there we go there you
go there's a guy sucking
yes oh he's got a big nice piece on him
there we go this guy's how do you feel
communion right here
there we go oh oh see it i don't think
to it like a duck to water
like a duck to watch i support it i see
like if i was in the scene
but does that arouse you you're not
really no open to it what would arouse
me
is if these same two men started talking
about the book
sapiens and how they got into that then
i might be able to get horny
and something introspective like that
and then i'd go to have sex with a woman
this right now i can watch this and i
can support this but
i don't it doesn't really uh you know
there you go i mean it's a little last
tap
yeah let me ask you this though because
this is really fascinating
for when you're talking about um
like being a sex because i think people
we always hear the term sex addict
but we don't really explore it like as
observers like with most people like
know uh or or have some knowledge of
right alcoholism right or drug addiction
right you go like well
it it you know it filled this void or
whatever it is right
is for you is the sex addiction that
same thing that was like trying to
fill some type of emptiness and you were
getting it through those sex acts
absolutely be and i didn't realize that
at first at first i was like oh
i'm a comedian on the road i'm i've been
laid
i'm yeah it's what happens it's part and
then i realize like the emptiness
after it was done on not only me the
woman too so i we would
constantly find each other and that's
what my therapist said he was like a lot
of times like a sex addict male will
find a sex addict female and
and he's like how often do you notice
like women that you would have sex with
that would never call you again or you
never call them again i was like almost
100 percent
how many how often would they leave like
right after you leave i was like within
10 minutes every time
it was like so it's you were both the
addiction addicts find each other wow
she was like so that's what you were
doing so i had to like just
cold turkey stop that and then i kept
would always like look
for something different something
different something different something
to fill the hole always
and you know i have a child and i you
know my
daughter was born we had the baby like
on like the second or third date like
wow yeah she got pregnant i was like my
life's crazy
spiraling smiling smiling not realizing
like no dude you're in the full you know
addict swing right now i had no idea
yeah and then a lot of things happen you
know like
you know ruined the relationship uh you
[ __ ] a lot of things up but i was like
oh but i love my daughter i'm always
there for my daughter
it's fine i'm you know telling myself
i'm a good father i'm there i'm present
but how many times would i push her in a
swing
dming a girl how many times was i like
hiding my phone how many times when
her mom would bring me over i would have
to clean the apartment realize all
addict behavior
so then i got i don't know if you ever
get through it i'm working
through it but at a way better place
than i am now back with
my child's mom back in like wholesome
family i've been out here for three
weeks
by myself you know how many temptations
of course and it's very easy
it's a lot easier now for me to be like
no that's not what's gonna give me
peace and balance what's going to what's
going to give because i realized
something
having so many options i realize is
actually not freedom
i kept saying to my kids mom i just want
to be free i
i but that's not it's the opposite of
freedom having too many options
is you're absolutely in chains yeah
freedom to me
now is having just one option one great
relationship with my daughter's mom the
concept of family building a family that
is like i feel totally free i feel like
i have so much energy here
for the last three weeks because i
haven't act i've been like
i'm only waiting for the call from the
one woman and the one family
and that's what it is now my hotel room
walls have gotten [ __ ] lit
up but that my therapist said that's
okay this guy's a [ __ ] loser cut his
mic
i know i know my dad's listening to this
like you [ __ ] hobo
i told you to pounce some ass out dear
christy
no you actually like hearing you say all
this stuff it
even seems like you are so much like
at peace and content with with like the
the
the ride you've been on to get here
right yes 100 and i feel
extremely like ready for
any type of maybe success that might
come my way and i'm not even and like oh
and my
values and my value system has changed
totally too like
for me now yes i want to do very well in
comedy of course
i'd love to have opportunities and do
that
but the val but really like the metric
for me is thing how my daughter is
developing and how my relationship with
her mom is developing in the concept of
family so if those things are going well
which they are right now
yeah i clean comes in i have a pilot
right now with true tv i mean it's my
tent pilot i'm [ __ ] chrissy pilots
i'm all for nine
if i go over 10 great dude i'm chrissy
strikeouts it doesn't matter
because my daughter's in a good school
and i have things that i want it's
awesome where it used to be
like two years ago like oh i need to get
this i'm a failure and it's like no
no like how many times are you going to
go through this so i didn't realize that
you know and yeah and i think like
saying hey i'm always working through
this addiction is a is a powerful thing
because colin quinn is like a
mentor of mine we've become very close
friends in new york and he's you know 30
years sober yeah and he was kind of the
one that first gave me the idea of like
have you ever thought about
you're addicted to this he's like
because
you know there's a lot of men that have
options or women that have options but
they don't act on them compulsively like
you are
right he's like you know how many times
are you going to bring four women into
the comedy cellar and
and he's like it's all great and good
and you know he's like i think
the women like you and you like them and
you're nice to them and kind to them and
it's all good but
how much how often how much do you want
to do this right and it's not fulfilling
you would not fear
all of it yeah you wouldn't believe it
being like this feels really great no
no no and they didn't feel good either
like you know everything obviously was
all good and consensual and
that was fine but it's i feel like you
just have to say that now yeah
it was all consensual just a real quick
side note didn't rape anyone
and yeah yeah so so but they felt empty
too because i i didn't even realize like
i noticed like
yeah they never call me ever again like
yeah if you if i text them and they'd be
like oh i had a great time but i'm just
not interested anymore it's like we were
fine the addicts were finding each other
yeah kind of wow how do you approach i'm
fascinated like how do you
approach the other one how do you sniff
her out like how do you know who's
broken enough to
you know the in opening message on a dm
right
right right you know what i mean really
yeah or the opening messages hey i
you know heart eyes or i think you're
hot or take me out for a drink and i'll
give you the night of your life things
like that i was like yes
yes where another girl was like hey do
you want to like take me to dinner i'm
like no
come on what are you gonna can i stick
garlic sticks up your [ __ ] yeah
no you know so i would not i was not
looking and then you know what i
realized too
it's just so [ __ ] gay just play gay
porn over this this is gayer than the
guy getting pounded in his ass
but it's just the truth i got a
lululemon pants any guys out there want
to hit me on grindr
i noticed too that you know my
girlfriend
my daughter's mom she constantly kept
taking me back after
[ __ ] up like you can't imagine like
constantly [ __ ] up but then being
like but i'm a nice guy i love my
daughter
constantly her being like this is your
last chance this is your last chance
and then finally you know just realizing
like that
is love on her part like i needed to
catch up to her because
that you know like you set the bird free
and if it comes back you know it's not
like that she's set me free so many
times and so many times i've been like
begging to come back and so many times
she's been like
come back yeah and now for like the pa
i've known her for
my daughter's five so we've known each
other five years and nine months so
so but this like past like six months
like in quarantine
has been like the most like fulfilling
with her and like the first time i'm
like
actually have listened to her and paid
attention to her and been like i want to
make this work where it used to be like
i don't even know you like we have a kid
and i don't even know you because i'm
just not paying attention because i'm
not interested i'm playing pretend i was
just constantly playing pretend with
everyone
so i had to just realize that like look
in the mirror and be like you [ __ ]
idiot but it's so it's so actually nice
to see somebody figure it out at your
age and yeah and that you're not like 70
being like you know what
yeah i think i [ __ ] up yeah and like
your life is you know i mean like you
you've put this together i mean just
hearing you talk about it i mean i can
see that like you've
you've really seen the light in this
whole thing yeah i mean yeah dude i mean
i'm
[ __ ] out condoms right now but you
know yeah it feels like that but it's
like
it's like you have to just admit that
too like where i was just like and also
like my circle
of friends like you know that changes
right i had to make it all a lot smaller
i just had to make it all a lot smaller
and stop
i was always the guy who was like what
do i do this advice and that advice and
asking 30 people their opinion did you
find that you would seek out the advice
of somebody that would reinforce bad
behavior
absolutely and it was the same thing
like you know
like the the options thing i would ask
for so many options because i thought
that's what oh i'll get all these
people's opinions when that is not
you're again that's the opposite of
freedom
you're now i'm like what do i do what do
i do where's just
who is your who's your crew who's your
circle of people and i have those people
yeah and i deal with them and then but i
ultimately like you know now make
my own choices and have just had to like
you know be crissy uncomfortable at
times and just tell people
how i'm honestly feeling which was
always like i just want you to like me
that's all i want you to do is like me
yeah
which is by the way the i think the mo
of like
almost all comedians truly is they're
yeah who then i saw a quote from my
favorite comedian bill cosby
and i i saw a quote from him that said
it said i don't know the secret to
success but i know the secret to failure
is trying to please everyone and i was
like wow
that guy's [ __ ] smart knows what's up
but the irony
is that his material was super universal
and
not inflammatory in the least i mean his
[ __ ] was like you go
dennis
what the [ __ ] yeah talk about your dick
weirdo i don't trust
that doesn't talk about his dick yes
you've been saying that for a decade but
you know why and i really think about it
because that's the dark side to all of
us comedians are
everywhere everyone has darkness dark
and light and if you're not
if you're not going in there and then
coming back out and making every
comedian we know
not addressing the dark not even the
public ones that everyone knows but some
of them who are real
like real clean and stuff you know them
because you hang out with them on a
level and you're like you are a [ __ ]
dark [ __ ] talk about it a little
bit man give us a little taste
and the thing is whenever you hang out
with them they're funnier
telling you those stories and you're
like why are you doing like i don't want
to do that on stage you're like why
yeah this is what's great so much better
like you're not being like like i feel
like the whole thing of this is like be
open and be cathartic and get
and it's like when i hear that yeah
though it's not even necessarily clean
because i know something
yeah you know but i i know the comedians
who like they're completely different
people on stage that's not
even like the [ __ ] it's not like
you're not cursing enough i'm saying
you're not exploring
you're you're on your truth your honesty
you know it's like they're yeah
they're just doing like surface levels
now i got to tell you something so
so i think i i'd heard your name a few
times
and it was i think last year not the one
that just passed but the year before
right that uh i think you posted a
september 11th
story from the seller yeah dude i
laughed
so hard oh thank you watching that and i
watched it a few times
and then this year you reposted it in
the same thing
it's like it's such a great here's what
it like that's
that that story you tell had you done
that on stage before
so it's so what happened was is i had
done that
kind of pseudo story in uh my comedy
central hour special
size 38 waste and um and uh
and uh it kind of came and went because
i was in a box and
you know like the rules like you can't
say this can't say that but then
actually on september 11th two years ago
i was like third or fourth com comedian
up at the comedy cellar and people were
bombing because they weren't addressing
yeah that it was 9 11. and i just went
on after a muslim comedian who didn't
address anything
and and i was just like you had a couple
drinks oh yeah
here's the thing the whole thing is
perfect because yeah
like you're a little loosey-goosey yeah
you're you're chrissy
five drinks in oh yeah and uh yeah and
the story is
unbelievable it's so it's so like
cinematic like there's so many
characters and layers you paint it just
perfectly and there's so many punch
lines that like
i i just kept going back to it it also
reminded me i think of what i
love about comedy before you do stand up
right because that story
is a story that like if you weren't a
comic and you
and you told that story like hanging out
yeah that's the kind of story where
you hear someone and you literally go
like you should you need to like you
should do comedy yeah
it's like it's a it's such a genuine
authentic real story i think chris is
going to masturbate after this podcast
it's a way the light hit one of his eyes
like yeah yeah i'm definitely yeah yeah
yeah
it is well cause you know what happened
because i was like drunk and like
uninhibited
like just like [ __ ] it go and i was like
you know what like it's 9 11.
i live through it i'm like a native new
yorker i feel like licensed to speak
freely like if you say you can't make
911 jokes like [ __ ] you my mom worked in
the building i know
yeah people that died like i feel like
it's my story
yeah you have credibility credibility
like you know i wasn't there but it's
like my mother was there and like i just
lived in
the highlight of this story is something
that i've
since sought out in your posts and
content
is talking about your dad i don't know
what it is that i'm so i'm so
lucky and blessed that i have this like
a great
dad like dad who you know he's always
been there and he's just like a sweet
guy
for some reason whenever somebody tells
me yeah like uh
sideways dad stories yeah i am i'm
fascinated and i laugh
beyond control like about like well like
i was talking to him this morning and he
was like what's going on today and i was
like oh i'm going to do
that that really you know big podcast i
was telling you about thompson he's like
oh yeah [ __ ] tommy segways
tommy segways he was like tommy segways
he was like hey he was like he seems
like a good kid i looked him up so he
just called you a kid okay
i'll call you yeah he was a guy seems
like good kids and then he was like oh
is this is
they married over there and i said yeah
i mean his wife christina he's like
that's nice that's you he's like you and
my girl's name is jasmine's like you and
jasmine should do something like that
yeah i was like she's not a comedian
always like who cares turn the cameras
on
that's what he said he's very much like
i love showbiz advice from a dad that's
yeah
yeah i said non-show business dad's
advice my the
73 74 years old diabetic heart condition
lives in you know new york now he just
moved to florida the next epicenter he's
just following oh yeah
he goes never smoked or drank a day in
his life
you know pandemic hits march it's like
april 1st you know
nobody's supposed to see their elderly
grandparents he's like i want to come
see the baby you know my daughter
he's like i got to come see the baby i
can't [ __ ] sit here anymore i'm like
yeah but you got to understand like you
can't like you're
you know old age you know like you're
you're every condition that they say is
going to kill you
you have them all he's like don't worry
about it i'm coming i'm going to get on
the bus i was like dad let me at least
yeah i was like let me at least come get
you he's like i'm getting on the [ __ ]
bus so he gets on the bus shows up he's
got a mask on
around his ear right around i'll never
forget it was around his left ear
he just got it hanging i'm like did you
take the bus like that he's again you
got a mask on your person
that's what de blasio said the mayor i
go i go but it has to
cross your face i was like dad it has to
be across your face yeah and then he
goes to me
he goes oh i'm sorry i thought june was
pride month i don't know i had a gay son
and then i'm like okay and then he goes
into my backyard
and lights up a cigar and i was like
what are you doing like you haven't
drank or smoked
anything and he was like let me [ __ ]
tell you one thing here chrissy
he goes nothing chinese is ever going to
take me down he goes my veins are red
white and blue
and he lights up these cigarettes yeah
it just starts coughing like an idiot
and i'm like dad
whatever he's not even a smoker he
doesn't care then
he didn't even tell me then i just call
him one day july 5th
i'm like hey you know like you want to
hang like you know i just had a barbecue
but then
i'm like um you know we just had a
barbecue in my house i was like you know
you want to come by we've got some
leftover food he's like oh i'm in tampa
florida
i was like what do you mean you're in
tampa florida because i moved here
i was like just drops it on you what
he's like yeah me and your stepmother
moved here so i was like
that's another epicenter of corona yeah
he was like red white and blue
baby that's what he said he just
constantly says red white and blue
chinese aren't gonna take me down
yeah it goes the chinese are not gonna
take me down dude his dad my grandpa
wouldn't eat sushi for the remainder of
his life he wouldn't eat sushi in 1995
because he thought it was the food of
the enemy
oh my god he just wouldn't and you're
dead
yeah but um yeah he uh well my dad was
in vietnam so
okay i don't want any of that noodles
and [ __ ] yeah
um which i guess it's like okay i mean
these guys fought in the war yeah
your dad growing up right must have been
it must have been wild
so he was a maniac um you know when my
mom so
so how they met was my because my
mother's very highly educated
woman like ivy league school like very
all about education and when you meet us
prim proper
you know comes very well to do not
wealthy but like
uh you know academics and speaks
properly like even my accent
should be like honey you need to
pronounce those r's okay you're not
going to sound like an idiot like your
father okay it's not going to happen
like you know like so she's like that
and my father's like a legit criminal
like was in and out of jail
and they were at my mother's company was
doing a walkathon in downtown manhattan
like i guess like 1983-84
and my dad was doing community service
on the side of the walk-a-thon no
prison work release like you have to do
when you get out you have to do a few
hours of community service and he was
like picking up garbage
like by like off like the fdr or
something wherever they were doing
like that park wherever they were doing
the walkthrough yeah he started flirting
with my mom my mom said
she was like she was like i'm walking in
the walk then all of a sudden one of
those garbage pickup things it pinches
my butt
and i turn around and she's like and
it's this ugly man with an orange
jumpsuit on
telling me how beautiful i am and that
he's going to rock my world
and i'm like and you know she's 20 years
old i would assume a virgin like
very she's like this is not what i want
you know but then he was so persistent
and she's you know kind of
goody two-shoes family just decided to
like have a fling
with a bad boy have me they have me
and then it's just like you know it's
like kind of history repeats itself
because then her whole life what because
then they got divorced immediately
because
you know catholic going pregnant let's
get married then divorced immediately
because my mother was like big mistake
yeah huge julie roberts voice
so huge big so
so so they get divorced and then my
mother's whole life was
keeping me on the like straight path so
right she was like you're gonna you're
not gonna make
the mistakes that i that i made that
your dad made you're gonna go to school
so everything i went to school
she's like no drugs no alcohol you're
gonna saw everything they asked me i did
sports did sports in high school college
even professional basketball overseas
you did yeah you played pro basketball
for like three weeks
and then and where it was uh first i was
on this team called darfusaka
in turkey and then and then um i played
got sent right back home quick for like
three days in ireland
sent home what were you a point guard
point guard i was a shooting guard in
college and then a point guard where'd
you go to college
st joseph's division three school yeah
yeah it was a very very small so you
gotta be a pretty decent basketball
player
well basketball was my whole life like
my father was all about sports my dad
was like you know he wanted to play
baseball and you know just
was a criminal and just didn't work out
the yankees like yeah you're a federal
you know your convict so like
george steinbrenner was like no what
kind of what kind of like
crimes was he involved all like like um
you know like racketeering and money
laundering and things like mob [ __ ]
yeah like but like you would never see
that's the thing like when you actually
have like a parent or like a close
family member who's in the mob like you
just don't you're just like yeah it just
happens like i remember one day
my one of my aunts her uh husband was
killed her husband and her son
i i was six months old so i guess my
cousin
um you know her husband was killed in
the and and the son was killed who
it was like 25 at the time all mafia
related stuff and then just
every month somebody would drop a bag
off in
cash i guess it was the family that like
whacked
my aunt's husband and their son like
that's was like old-school mafia attack
just like whatever
they did they're like the wife shouldn't
have to pay for it so they like take
care of the bills and like i like i was
like five years old one day and just
opened the door and some guy was like
give this to your aunt
and i was just like a bag of you know i
i don't know how much team
no another aunt on my dad's side and so
that's just like but so like you learned
to like you know
that's just part of the thing just
normalizing it yeah anytime i hear
anybody be like you know who my [ __ ]
father is uncles i'm like probably
nobody
because those guys are like you would
never even know like you know you're
just like
they just kind of act the way they act
like my dad's
my uncle he wasn't my dad's brother but
it was like close uncle like i had an
uncle bobby pets
who he's a real guy and he had like all
these animals and he [ __ ] loved
animals
when i was a kid when i was kid i was
like oh he's just got like like a little
petting zoo like
in his backyard he always had like crazy
[ __ ] he had like a penguin i never
forget it was like summer like 1996 in
brooklyn
guys if penguin walked i swear it was
like it was like july 4th weekend
well i don't remember how he got it but
i do remember the penguin
me and my dad go into his house bobby
pence's house like the next week
and he had like a like an air
conditioner and two fans on
but it was like you know sweltering new
york city heat and i was like i feel
like i was like 12 at the time you know
like
all about like science and all that was
like i don't think like this is
mimicking
like antarctic conditions yeah
frigidaire [ __ ] air conditioner
which is like rattling
in a basement and then he was feeding a
cheese and i was like i swear to god i
just feel like
that's not international no yeah it died
it died a week later oh
yeah oh my god and then my dad and bobby
pants buried the penguin off the side of
the new jersey turnpike this
a lot of times i feel like you're making
[ __ ]
yeah so so that's kind of how my dad
operated yeah so he ran with like some
real legit
but before like i was a kid you know
like so when i was a k
by the time i he had the one incident on
september 11th where i really saw like
wow this guy's a [ __ ] nut drum but
since then he's like you know
i mean he's still the same guy like he's
but he's gotten older and like a lot you
know yeah like i remember when i met
you know my kid's mom you know she's a
beautiful puerto rican girl and like i
remember my dad's like sitting there he
was like you got a hot mom for the old
man i'm like you're
on dialysis yeah right now with your
wife standing right next to you
and then like you know and then she's
like it's like a crazy like kind of like
life and um but he's like a great guy
and like the
my dad is like right intentions wrong
move like the best father
you could ever ask for like he's never
missed a moment anything
significant in my life my father's been
there always but you know before i was
born i think he was just like living
sure crazy life was crazy people and
still there's craziness there but he was
always like
the he's the best dad like and the best
grandfather you know like
absolutely like because he's like this
tough guy but
i remember we were cleaning out uh my
daughter's uh
room when she got a little older maybe
she was like two or three and we found
like these stuffed animals and they had
little diapers on them and i was like
who was putting diapers on the stuffed
animals and my stepmom was like your
father was practicing diapers
while the baby was coming that's cute
but you know he would never admit how
did he
how did he react because it's always
interesting how did he react to like the
story the you know the 911 story like
you telling it he he when i started
doing comedy
he was always like whatever you want to
do like i'll support you so like he was
like you know obviously don't mention
the real names of some of these guys
he's like because i just you know
i don't want to i don't want you to get
in trouble he's like but whatever you
want to do do so even like because you
know
i was a physical therapist so i had to
get
like a doctorate degree to become a
physical therapist because i told you my
mother was all about education
so so for her she was like you're not
going to end in college like you need to
go through graduate school
so i went all the way to get it's funny
too
it's just like it's sometimes like i
start telling stories i'm like oh i
remember this my dad first of all i you
know it's a doctorate level
program so it's like you're with some
like really ritzy kids right yeah you
know
smart kids whatever and you know i
applied myself i think i
i got into the graduate program like i
don't i got in for
my grades were okay my gpa was okay but
i think because i played on teams almost
like about teamwork
the dean took a chance at me and let me
i don't think i should have qualified
for the doctorate level program
but i proved myself that i could do it
because i had like a good gpa and just
supplied myself
so i was proud and i was actually second
in line to be the valedictor
i tied jesus i tied with which is like
crazy because i was like you know an
idiot
kid from brooklyn that you know talks
like a [ __ ] sewer cap but then i have
like a
3.9 gpa in a doctorate level program so
they
it was between me and this girl who was
valedictorian because we both
are tied and they were like you know who
do you want to give the speech and i
i was like look the way i talk and look
i probably shouldn't
give the speech you know because i'm
just people even when i was a physical
therapist they i would be like oh hi you
know welcome like what's going on
they're like can i as you're are you
going to see the real therapist or
are you the boss you know when the first
day of physical therapy school the
the dean nice woman cause you know it's
a whole application process she didn't
know
exactly who i was yet you know it was
just names on the list
i showed up i was like oh i'm looking
for room 501. she was like are you the
are you the maintenance crew are you
here to clean because we had a spill i
was like no i'm a student she was like
what's your name and then just like
looking she's like oh okay
yeah and then like you know had to prove
it but after because you don't sound
like one of our students
no she was like you don't look like
heaven yeah you have a bag of cash like
that's just what i did always i'm like
do i need this
and then um and then so my dad is like
again first of all
chuck schumer you know talked at the
thing they had
it was like a very like kind of
religious
it was a public school but they wanted
to like make sure all the bases were
covered so you had chuck schumer
senator from new york talking for like
the jews and then you had
um a catholic uh priest like a cardinal
um
a bishop i meant talking and then you
had a like a muslim
uh what is it a shaman not a shaman an
imam
what does it even know and elon omar
what is it you know
i don't know what it is the you know a
muslim priest a muslim high priest a
[ __ ]
sultan yeah i don't know but a good guy
a good muslim kid an imam yeah
imam okay so he starts dude there's like
you know it's like
you know a thousand people and the
imam starts doing a prayer in muslim and
we're like very much like you know i'm
sitting with the student body
again getting a doctorate degree so it's
prestigious and you know it's like in
arabic or something yeah and it's in
arabic
and then my like weights are like dead
signs and my dad just yells out from the
back hakuna matata
and then people are like that and i knew
and that's the thing
you had 500 people all turn around
except me
i was looking straight i knew it was my
[ __ ] and i was like nope
no i'm just going to keep looking
straight ahead yeah just straight ahead
there's there's something by the way
it's a consistent thing you find
because i moved a lot yeah there was a
always the kid
yeah with the eccentric dad yes who was
always
not amused no either but everybody else
was no
like one of my best friends in high
school his dad
when i met him i went like i met him in
school and i got to hang out i go to his
house
and his dad has a heavy accent cuban guy
he goes are you here to pick up my
little girl today
what and he's like he's like my little
girl are you here to pick her up
and i go uh yeah and he comes out and
he's like just
straight face and he's like hey see i
see you met my dad yeah
and he goes uh and i go yeah and he goes
what
are you two little [ __ ] going to do
today i was like
uh so but as i'm laughing he's just like
okay dad
good like and every time for four years
and actually you know for the 20 cents
yeah if i see him his dad will
say call us something like retards or
fat sure and like and do a whole thing
yeah he sang a song calling us homos
yeah
and like and every time my friend is
straight faced yeah
and all everybody else is dying well
because
you know even from like an early age
like you said you were young when that
happened
like even you know that happened when i
was whatever 27 but
flashback i was like eight were at my
cousin's recital and it was just me
my dad and my cousin because the our
moms couldn't make it because they were
working or something so
you know saturday afternoon like you
know the the ballet is going on the
recital and
you know a bunch of eight and
nine-year-old kids and little girls
doing it and my cousin's up and it's
nice i mean you know i'm a kid i'm like
kind of paying attention i don't really
care i'm just like dragged there
and my dad's there like reading the
paper he doesn't care same thing back
row
and then the the like leader like the
teacher of the ballet was like maybe
like a 25 year old
woman you know like really pretty woman
from what i can remember any and
you know it's like intermission i might
i never forget my doesn't go this is
nice it's half time
i've never called it halftime and it's
like intermission and it's like you can
hear like a pin drop again like dead
silence and she's like about to say
something like hey like it's
intermission whatever and my dad just
yells i'll never forget like
it was like in slow motion he goes show
you bush
and then starts laughing at the other
dance and nobody's laughing
and i remember being a kid like just
like knowing like
this is not right yeah like that's not i
was like oh boy
and then like you know like he would but
again like the
the greatest father like like i can't
explain to you like
such a great dad everything i mean he
just wanted to make sure i had a good
life and
it was like again like right intentions
wrong move like he took me
yeah sorry but isn't it so upsetting
when nobody laughs i mean did anybody
laugh at the akuta matata that that was
really funny yeah the hakuna matata i
don't
remember if anybody laughed because you
go in you probably had adrenaline
shooting through your body
yeah i mean you're just like yeah i do
you know
my family members would laugh like my
cousins knew who were there like they're
like it's [ __ ] hilarious that's the
best
yeah the uncle doing that is the best i
mean it's just you know
maniac guy but again like just really
like well-intentioned man chrissy it's
all destroyed bush
go to bush look you've known me for
years and you know what i value the most
is therapy i myself have been in therapy
for a decade it has changed my life and
i know sometimes it takes a long time
before you
get your stuff together and you go not
anymore there's no excuse not to do
therapy
with talk space i know even when money's
tight you're like i don't
i don't want to invest in myself but it
should be at the top of your mind
because mental
health is a necessity not a luxury
with talkspace online therapy you can
connect with a licensed therapist for a
fraction of the price
of in-person therapy get matched with
your perfect therapist from the comfort
of your device and reach out 24
7 whenever something's on your mind
which is huge because you don't have to
wait until your next appointment
unlike in person therapy sessions
talkspace gives you 24 7 access
uh to your online therapy room it's
affordable and there's a huge network of
therapists to choose from
and talk space is secure and private the
bottom line is we all need someone to
talk to talkspace wants to give us the
support we deserve
at a price we can't afford as a listener
of this podcast you get 100
off your first month on talkspace to
match with your perfect therapist
go to talkspace.com or download the app
make sure
to use the code your mom to get 100
off your first month and show your
support for the show that's your mom
and talkspace.com oh my god i was at
dwight goodin's no-hitter in 1996
and um and uh we're at the game and like
the upper deck and my dad's like knows
like
dwight gooden's pitching a no-hitter
like it's and i'm you know a little kid
i'm just happy to be at the game with my
dad and my dad's like we're not gonna
[ __ ] watch you know hit it from up
here we gotta go down behind home plate
and i'm like well we don't have tickets
for that you know he's like just listen
to everything i tell you to do
it's like a swear to god like true 100
story this is like
crazy and um i've told this i've told
this story before but it's
it's like just like sometimes when i'm
talking it's like oh i forgot about that
part
because it's just like certain things
block out and then certain things you're
like oh that's what happens
so just to set it up so for people
you're at a major league baseball game
where a major event is
a very rare thing is happening yes
you're in bad seats
yes and you want to get to the primo
seats and you're like we don't have
tickets and your dad's like follow my
lead
also yes also i forgot about this part
also it's 1996
i'm in uh sixth grade my father i had a
humongous science project due the next
day that i did not complete in time my
father comes from staten island to pick
me up
for the game my mother's like tony i
don't care what's going on again no cell
phones yet
i don't care what's going on you leave
after the third or fourth inning he
needs to be home to wake up early
tomorrow morning to finish the science
project
those are the rules i don't care he
needs to come home and do not give him
any soda
as soon as my mother shuts the door we
get to the corner my dad takes out a
[ __ ] mountain dew
the worst of all sodas yeah just takes
it out gives it to me there you go
he goes here you go he goes just don't
obviously don't tell your mom he goes
but i mean she can't deprive you of
everything i mean you're a kid yeah so
like we're drinking the mountain dew and
i'm [ __ ] wired i'm like ready to go
i'm like i love my dad
you know and then i told my dad you know
it was like maybe like nine o'clock and
i'm like oh it's like the third or
fourth inning goes we'll stay one more
raining like whatever like it's what's
we'll tell your mother's train problems
don't worry about it so i'm like okay
so then it's like the fifth inning sixth
inning seventh inning and you're
gonna hit my dad's like she's gonna
understand
she's gonna understand dwight's pitching
to no no i'm like i don't think my mom
knows what that is or cares she doesn't
like sports or right she hates you
and she doesn't like sports so i feel
like she's gonna care and it's gonna get
bad but i'm 12 years old i'm hanging
with my dad i'm on mountain dew and hot
dogs and [ __ ] having a great time
with my dad so i'm like this is awesome
so he goes just follow everything i tell
you to go
he's holding my hand and as he's holding
my hand he goes take your hat off
because we're going to yank yet any i
never i swear he pushes my bangs down
i don't know what that means just pushes
my bangs down he holds my hat i'm like
okay
so we're going down and then the
security guard you know this is again
pre-911 so you could just walk around
the stadium
so the security guard's there at the top
of the seats that are going directly
down behind home plate
and he sees two or three open seats he
goes hey i see two or three open down
there can i just you know it's my kid's
[ __ ] first game and
dwight's pitching a no-no like you
understand my dad's going to pull out
cash
you know cash and the security guard
says put your money away that's not
going to work on me he goes i understand
he goes well my kid's got special needs
i
swear and then i look up at him like
with like my mouth open because i don't
know what to do and i swear like i
didn't mean for this app and i was such
in shock that some drool did come out
of my chin and then the security guard
rubs me on my head and goes have a good
time kid
and we sit down in these two seats the
row in front of me it's like a 12 year
old's wet dream i'm like [ __ ] and then
it's like a complex i'm like do i look
like i have special needs because nobody
ever told me i did
but you know like it's like i remember
walking down the steps like what the
[ __ ] am i dad like you did good the
drool was a good touch
and i'm like i don't know what to say or
do
and then the row is fun
i swear to god i don't know what to do
dude the row in front of me
the row [ __ ] directly in front of me
i'm 12 years old 1986
mr perfect the wrestler mr perfect
sitting in front of me i loved the wdf i
was a kid
mr perfect sitting right there i'm like
dad that's mr perfect and he's like
who's that
and i'm like he's a wrestler like my
favorite is oh my god and then i'll
never forget he goes yo
perfect drop the mister he goes yo
perfect he goes can my son get an
autograph
and then mr perfect says no i swear mr
perfect says no
yeah and then like a few minutes right
here yeah mr perfect and then my a few
minutes go by
a few minutes go by and my dad taps him
on the shoulder and goes perfect
kid's got special needs i swear to god
and then i got the autograph
and it's one of those things where
people like you make that up for a bit
like it's too
and i'm like no no no you have to
understand i didn't want to do comedy
my therapist was the one who decided who
suggested it when i was in my mid-20s
like you ever think about doing comedy
are you serious i swear to god
he was like dr feidelberg in brooklyn he
was like i just think like you're a
personable guy and
you should tell some of these stories
because i would tell them not in a funny
way and the vital burden they're
like telling them be like you know it
really hurt me kid's got special needs
your kids got special needs i was like
it kind of bothered me that my dad would
say that to me or
you know it feels insulting like i love
history like i have a podcast now that's
history hyenas historians
right me and janice pappas we both love
history so much we come from different
parts of brooklyn but we love history so
much but for
so long i was suppressing that because
my dad would just [ __ ] say like in a
loving way like history is for homos
like even when i said the history hyenas
he was like the history almost no and i
was like
yeah it's a huge so
so all these things about me that i just
thought were like i thought it was gay
between my dad and his friends and my
brooklyn all my friends are cops firemen
garbagemen criminals like
old school new york guys that are loving
great guys yeah but it's just like
all like i thought if you had knowledge
or if you wanted to go to school it was
like that's
you know you might as well be sucking
dick yeah so i was just suppressing it
all
and just pushing it down and be like
okay i'm not gay i'm not gay i'm not gay
knowledge is for homos
because it would be like everybody
dropped out like you know like even when
i got my doctorate degree like i
remember one of my friends like he
didn't get it
he was like i don't understand you
[ __ ] went to college like you just
went to college and now you're going to
another college you get stupid
go back-to-back colleges i'm like i'm
getting a doctorate degree he's like but
are you a [ __ ] real doctor
i was like no i'm a physical therapist
yeah he was like can you write me
prescriptions
and i was like why do you want to know
he's like i just want some xanax
that's [ __ ] street value you must
have your dad's friends you must be
there must be some wild friends hanging
out like your dad's friends
like bobby pets all those yeah like
barbecues i didn't realize like when you
go to a
barbecue at my father's house in the 90s
like so much fun like
characters and characters i do a joke
about it and um
i did david leonard david letterman
another story [ __ ]
there if you want ever watch my david
letterman you don't have to but the only
reason i bring it up is because
about three minutes into the biggest set
of
my life at that time for sure um
you see like me look up and then look
down and then like get back into the set
it's because
my father mother and uh one of my
friends from home and my aunt were there
like
my stepmom you know my core family
members and friends
um my dad in the middle of the set
decides
that my mom is the one sitting center
and he was like you weren't and
you know my friend told me after he's
like there was a commotion
that you could hear because it's pin
drop silence where my dad was arguing
with my mother that
they should switch sheets and he should
be center and if he's gonna look up in
the crowd to see him
and then my friend was like he was like
hey cause lin you weren't at his first
show at the maui taco
i was and they're arguing about it and
my mother during the set during the
letterman said that the ushers came down
the eye because they don't [ __ ] around
yeah the ushers came down the aisle and
were like you know like my friend was
like you know the flashlight like
hey because they they know who's sitting
where they're like hey we know that your
kid if you don't stop we will throw you
out
and then my dad was just like you know
like looked ahead like pissed off and my
mother was just like so and like i heard
that commotion but that's just
that's why you look that's why i look up
because i heard it and i was like oh boy
and you knew what it was i knew what it
was but again like
that's like wrong of my dad but he's
just like i'm just [ __ ] so proud that
that's my kid of course
so so it's um but i tell a story
uh a bit on letterman about um one of my
dad's friend they were like
i always noticed and it's just like a
true thing i always noticed that
they always had like companies that i
knew weren't real that's how i knew like
there was some illegal activity going on
because i was like there's not a real
company because my one of my dad's
friends he had a company i made up like
nickname for him for the show but the
truth is that
he would sell like you know like on
fences like there's little
parts like like excess wire yeah he told
me once that's what his company goes you
ever go in a fence a nice neighborhood
there's a little twisty things on top of
the [ __ ] pipes i make those that's
what i do
i sell the twisties then i had another
guy tell me that he put buttons on top
of hats he's like i got a company we do
buttons on top of hats
it's called button heads and i just as a
kid like i was like oh this is funny but
it was like they were
making up yeah why did they what's funny
though is it do they make it so
uninteresting
like that you're like you know when
you're on an airplane back in the day
and someone's like what do you do for a
living the last thing you say is
comedian
no you're a [ __ ] button maker and is
that why you think they came up with
such silly
you know pen caps yep i make those
[ __ ] pictures so nobody wants to hear
it
i think because you know my mom you know
it's very
different lives like monday to friday
was my mom all about education
we're working on our words we're
pronouncing our ours we're going to be
kind of socially acceptable and then
weekends with my dad on staten island
was just free-for-all whatever you want
[ __ ] let's go crazy sports
you know whatever you're gonna be a man
that type of stuff
so i my mother would always say like you
know like when you go into a party you
know introduce yourself
ask a question show you're interested
all that stuff so i would just like you
know
thought that apply to everyone but i
remember like one of my dad's friends i
was like oh hey what do you do for a
living and i remember he said he said
what are you writing a [ __ ] book
report
he's like this kid's right he's like
tony and then i've never forgetting says
every day goes tony i mean it's [ __ ]
kids you're talking to feds
dude this [ __ ] kid you know like you
know and i was like oh like ah
you know like you're like i'm just
saying i was i can't slow my birthday
party i'm just welcoming
and you know and and then that they
would go into that and then yeah like my
i remember it was always a good sign by
the way if you just ask someone like one
question like what's your
what's with the questions like i'm just
asking you like one [ __ ] question is
my first question yeah these kids
writing a [ __ ] book report
and then it was like then they would
joke around like after like they always
tap me down for a wire which was like
funny to them and they would laugh
like i feel like what the [ __ ] you know
they were like this kid's wearing a wire
and then um but he was kidding but then
i kind of like was always on the fence
it goes like i don't know if they are i
don't know if they are and i don't ask
any questions i don't care like i love
being with my dad and he's a great guy
or whatever
but then it was maybe like 2 000 i don't
remember the exact year maybe 2007
humongous sting operation in new york
where they arrested like
130 members of the mafia like it was the
biggest
they had to rent out a gymnasium to like
and bring a judge in because it was
this huge sting operation that like
effectively put like the final nail in
like the old school mafia's coffin after
giuliani
institute of rico act it took like 20 15
years for everybody to start to go away
but this was like the kind of thing and
then i it was on the news
they showed all the guys like the mug
shots and like 15 of them were at my
dad's barbecue throughout the years i
was like
okay so now i know yeah now i don't
remember that's like all these guys
i know that guy that guy that guy that
guy that guy that guy i'm like
here we go so um but yeah
i mean again just the [ __ ] like the
greatest dad
in the world dude even like stories like
that aren't really
even like cause i just feel like it's
like unfair
in like these times now where like the
woke police will just like
want to persecute someone it's like very
like fascist where like if you don't
agree with me you're like the worst
person like my dad
like anything my dad said around like
some woke person
i mean would be like what the [ __ ] like
you know my dad would not get a netflix
special right now you know like
they're like no and and
not happening but like like in 2012 when
hurricane sandy happened
ravaged new york destroyed new york
especially staten island where my dad
lives
and on the coast there were like these
little bungalows where like a lot of
like
you know like latinos lived and it was
like kind of like like
low income housing but it was mostly
latinos living there and my dad
every day would rent a u-haul truck or
whatever help them
unload stuff in and out of the truck uh
you know get them on their feet for two
weeks
he had a family in his house because his
house wasn't really damaged in his
basement
let them live would take the kids to and
from school every day
but he was still my dad so like for
example like the the leader of the
family the father his name was jose my
dad would call him juan
he's like juan you want some bastello
you know we don't have stella he'd be
like hide the silverware you're not
gonna steal my forks [ __ ] pedro
i'm like the kid's name is jason you
know and
but like the act so you know like the
intentions were i'm gonna help this
so you would talk to you would talk to
the family and they'd be like still
they're like your dad is like our hero
i feel like reasonable people get that
that is
just like the layers of human beings
right i know that you're like
there's a guy who's doing great things
and he makes off-color comments and
jokes
right it's only like in today's world
where people make the biggest deal
about the comments and then dis discard
the act
the behavior look at people's behavior
that's how you judge a man
not by well that's what i feel too like
stupid i'm kind of
realizing too i don't know if you guys
are realizing it like there's also like
an entitlement in being a victim too
like being a victim is like you're just
as entitled for some people and you're
just as narcissistic
as the people that you claim to hate you
know if you hate trump or you hate
anybody in power you're like you're just
you everything being
it's like life is not easy there's a
difference everybody there's different
phases and
every group of human beings every decade
we have to deal with a new crisis that's
just what life is but it's like
if you're going to sit here and say that
2020 is not
is is worse than the 1800s in new york
it's like you're being a victim you're
being entitled to being narcissistic
it's like
stop like really understand like how
good things are even in the midst of a
pandemic
as compared to the 1800s or 1900s it's
absurd
but you know most people if you say that
they're like [ __ ] you
yeah you know like so it's like it's
just a little like exhausting now where
i'm like
i like people in the middle i like
centrist people i'm like if you're
taking a [ __ ] stand on
one side or the other i'm just like
you're probably too much for me
like i need to know i'm chrissy down the
middle i'm chrissy grayson's yeah so
which way is it gonna go
you know that's what i like i think most
reasonable people are
absolutely yeah i think so yeah yeah do
the right thing in november you know do
the right thing
make america great again keep it great
i'm joking i'm glad you mentioned it
trump 2020
no no i actually don't know
[Music]
vote for the donald trump is the man
let's put our nation into his hands
mike pence and donald make a great team
they'll make our nation the greatest
it's been
they've got the wisdom courage and pride
criminal clinton ought to go hide
they know our borders leak like a sieve
they'll build a wall that's high it's
strong and it's not gonna
give well there's more of that but you
understand well do we finish the wall or
not
it's coming very patriotic very pretty
great guy no great guy nice chain too
jesus
height and weight and gold on the chain
like that that's something my dad would
wear
with a yankees batting practice jersey
oh my god yeah
that's all that guy would wear and
[ __ ] suit jackets sweatpants
yeah you know good my kind of did you
know actually when we moved to florida
when i was 14.
and i got my hair cut i ever tell you
this by a
really italian new york guy named silvio
okay
i need a heavy accent and he would take
two hours to cut my hair
because he would go like clip clip and
he step step back and just talk yeah
people are like
nothing yeah he would talk and i found
him like so entertaining
sure and over time you know i get to
know those guys cutting my hair
year and one year two years so i'm like
you know i always
start pressing questions right yeah like
so when did you move down here
yeah he's like uh happened like like 98.
what are you doing police no he's like
he's a real sweet guy
and then one day just through all the
italian stories and stuff and i go
did you ever know any like mob guys up
there he just stopped and he was like
yeah
and i go what did like did you know him
he's like and he just
one day he just tells me he goes so this
crew
used to use my shop as a meeting place
because they needed a place that wasn't
compromised
and i go so how did it work he goes they
would a guy would just come in
and say we need to talk here and then i
would go for a walk
and then i would when i came back they
would be gone
and there would just be cash on the
table and i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah i mean of course i'm a high school
kid i was like that's awesome he's like
it was [ __ ] terrifying man
yeah and then and then and then i'm like
so why did you move down here though and
he was like
because yeah you got to get away yeah he
moved down to florida just to get away
from that
yeah yeah i would too anytime you ask
like an old italian man or
i i'd say it's mostly italian if you're
like from new york and you ask them all
what'd you do for a living if they say
many things
you know they're telling you that i'm in
the mafia that's like the little code
yeah they say many things that's how you
know i had a
friend whose uh dad was uh
into crimes that was a latin
and in the latin the world what they say
when you know they're
in like definitely a criminal import
export
yeah yeah if you go down to miami and
you're like what's your guy doing
like what what do you import and export
though like yeah goods like
clothes and they're like all types of
things all the time yeah drugs that's
what it is yeah yeah import export
good yeah that's a could you have a more
vague description
of your job export port export
my dad was always friends with these old
school hungarians that were like missing
knuckles
one guy he's dead now he he would do
this thing where he would refill
ink ink cartridges okay like he would
get them out of dumpsters and then
refill them and sell them as new
yeah and he made millions of dollars
doing this
and then he would make it all off the
books he had no social security number
anyway he ended up getting cancer in
miami and couldn't get
health insurance because he had no
social security number couldn't get
anything and had to pay cash for all of
his cancer treatments and like
basically lost all the money from being
[ __ ] from all his crimes it's real sad
which sucks for him you want to keep you
know what i mean your cash from your
crimes
yeah just want to know then there was
that one hungover
that i met at a party hungary's like uh
we're like when somebody made the
comment like he had the
slim waist exactly looking good he goes
one apple
one apple a day that's what you eat he's
like all day he goes for lunch i have an
apple that's it
that's it that's all you need i'm like
that's not all i need dude yeah i'll
tell you
i'm skinny i need a lot more do you want
to lose weight
i've had three starbucks pumpkin scones
this morning three they're 500 calories
each
chrissy [ __ ] hips christie yeah i just
yeah dude yeah i need to [ __ ] eat
yeah i just gotta eat [ __ ] i get angry
i feel like your dad would be a fan of
damn pena do you know dan payne
thank god
[ __ ] and why have i been so [ __ ]
successful over these 25 years
because it [ __ ] works and the reason
you're here you snowflake [ __ ]
is because nobody treated you like [ __ ]
tough love works
your [ __ ] weenies oh i love this guy
yeah he's the best
i mean that guy like literally that's a
guy that's a guy for me yeah yeah
you know that's a guy for me i don't
care it's like what political
affiliation's like
i'm just looking at him as a human being
that's a guy for me yeah
i love that [ __ ] dan you got the money
okay i got
yeah i got a few bob yeah okay you
support trump
okay i was one of the first endorsers
public endorsers
of president trump's to do when our
ocean level rises
thank you for asking that question i
have the answer then don't let me finish
i have the answer let me finish well
thank you for the question
yeah okay for the first time on earth
we're changing the gas now you're full
of [ __ ] sit down
i'm going to answer you i'm going to add
this shut up and
shut up and sit down sit down
i live for this state florida for
example which is one of the fastest
growing
yes i just love it this guy's a 10 out
of 10. oh he's amazing hanging out with
losers
wasting your time with people that means
correct show me your friends and i'll
show you your future
that's one of your top top it is three
pieces show me your friends
and i'll show you your future you want
to know why you're all [ __ ] up
just look at the [ __ ] bums you hang
around with
dude it's authentic this is totally
nothing that's what i that's what i'm
drawn to is
[ __ ] real he's a real guy this is why
you're [ __ ] poor
you're a [ __ ] brian not me i love it
isn't he the best
the best i can't have never heard of
this guy oh he's saying this
has anyone ever said [ __ ] you damn pena
i'm walking out the door
no i've thrown a couple out but nobody's
ever said that no i take that back one
uh
one romanian walked out the door because
he said i was making fun of him calling
him a gypsy aroma but then when we came
back in the afternoon he was sitting in
the library
and i thought i i thought you left he
says no no no you were right you're
sorry i'll be the first
if i walk yeah yeah if you walk you'll
be well you'll be there there'll be
plenty of [ __ ] here but you may be the
first [ __ ] to walk out
there's something sweetest guys have you
guys ever had him on the show yeah yes
and we had then we had lunch we had
lunch with him
because he just same wonderful guy he's
actually you know like he's
he is authentically the same guy um i
remember i was like hey
i was like can i get some you know
you're a business coach so yeah i get
some business advice and he's like yeah
what about and i go um like to you know
what's like a good advice for me like
he's like well like how do you make most
of your money
yeah and i go uh touring doing stand-up
shows she goes do more [ __ ] shows
yeah and i was like is that the advice
yeah yeah make more money do more shows
[ __ ] face and i was like
all right thanks man yeah no but
business-wise you guys are
fantastic with the business i mean
fantastic like
absolutely um admirable and
inspirational like even the um
the live uh show streaming shows yeah
yeah
i'm i'm trying to do one i'm doing one
on october 23rd 8pm christy comedy.com
but i was like man like watching the way
you guys promo and all that stuff i'm
like
that's like you guys are obviously
excellent at the show but the business
part
which i think a lot of us forget in
entertainment is like
that's important way yeah as important
maybe more
you know where i'm like man like [ __ ]
that's that's what we got to do so i've
been trying to focus more on that like
how do i
i got to like bring people to that's why
i've been on patreon
a lot because i feel like man if they
can cancel anybody out here like we got
to have a place where it's like
yeah i want to be able to say whatever
the [ __ ] i want and if the
person wants to pay five bucks for it
they can pay five bucks for it you know
well
good and because the gatekeepers of this
business are no longer the gatekeepers
no
they have no more power no no manager no
agent none
no executive is going to get fired in
two [ __ ] weeks is going to control
you and no more
and there and good good riddance you can
do it all yourself you don't need them i
feel like the algorithm
the algorithm is the gatekeeper now
that's right you know that's right and
it's smart of you to be doing
that stuff and doing your livestream
yeah i'm doing the live stream and
what's your live stream
is it um a stand-up live stream or just
like stand up i was going to do stand up
where are you going to do it wall street
theater norwalk connecticut and you're
going to stream it
stream it so there's 100 only 100 people
allowed in the theater those tickets are
sold out but then
you know on my website you can like
stream that's great i can get as many
in as you know whatever 50 000 seats
whatever so i'm gonna
you know try to like give people an
opportunity if i've never come to your
city or all over the world i mean
anywhere so do it keep it up for 48
hours
people get the tickets for that
chrisdcomedy.com chrisdcomedy.com yeah
and then um actually we just did an
episode on the history hyenas
podcast it's about um this guy clarence
king
who's like we call him like the original
sean king because like sean king you
know you guys know
king it's like you know it's like
activist activist but he's clearly white
he's just saying he's black you know
like we did like a whole episode
and by the way every time that anything
happens and like he says something
all of black twitter just goes [ __ ] this
piece of [ __ ]
yeah it's un it's remarkable yeah you're
like what like dude i don't
the only problems i have is like okay
you want to start you know if you're
starting something with a lie it's like
a problem but it's okay if you're doing
good for the community
great but it's like a lot of times he'll
lie and like incite [ __ ] and you're like
that's the issue i have with you dude
yeah
but so we found this guy clarence king
who pretty much like just like
liked this like he was a white guy and
then he just saw a black woman walking
towards him in like the 1920s and was
like
there's no way this girl is going to go
out with me if i say i'm white so he
just introduced himself
as a black man he was like hey i'm black
here's my name and then they got married
like
10 years later but if you google the
picture clarence king this guy looks
like you we were calling him [ __ ]
i was calling him tom segura on the
podcast let's see yeah he said clarence
king google clarence king and then just
images
one of the pictures we thought look at
that that one the third one
i was like that looks like tom segura a
little bit tommy yeah so clarence king
and i was like there he is there you are
and to see like that's an episode
that like we put it out yeah we black
i'm black and if you're black i would
like to have sex with you too yeah
it's just a fascinating thing that's
what our podcast is or we just find
things in history that's
that's fact so this dude that's really
what happened he just
literally walked oh and then go to the
picture to the right there because that
must be him in the lady that's the same
in his lady
oh yeah but he had to he had to um where
was what city was he in
um i think i'm forgetting that i think
it was either ohio or new york
why is he notable like why is there a
wiki of him because because he
at the end of his so he had a wife he
had a white wife and three white kids
and then married this woman oh his black
wife and had kids with her
and it was only on his deathbed did he
ever say
hey i'm white i've i've never been black
because back then in that time in like
the in this time
if you because the white man was like so
on top
you just have to believe what he said so
if i'm if i'm a white man saying hey
guess what i'm black
as a black woman or you have to just
pretty much just go with it yes
because if not like you could be trouble
in your life so that's but he was like
but for the most part black women
wouldn't date
black men like they'd be a black woman
wouldn't date white men so
he just like made a split second
decision like he was like this girl's
got [ __ ]
it's hot yeah so i'm gonna just say i'm
black for the rest of my life so he left
his white wife
no he had his wife and white wife and
kids and he would go on business trips
back
back and forth but the controversy was
at the end of his life on his death but
he left his
inheritance he had a lot of money he
left it to the black wife because he
really fell in love with her i loved her
and she never got the money in 30 years
later but we just did like the first
sean king because it was like right
clearly sean king yeah that's a great
granddad we just always thought it was
like a funny thing that's very funny but
like episodes like this
like we did a lot of it on youtube but
then like when we really started getting
[ __ ] nuts and wild
you know we just put it on patreon
that's the way to do it that's just what
we do
so that's the way to do it and like all
like on patreon like we're doing a
morning show there
every wednesday like you're saying wild
[ __ ] about the news we do conspiracy
show we do like
you guys have good chemistry we feed it
yonas and i try to feed it so it's
patreon.com slash bay ridge boys if you
guys want to
check it out and support and because i
just feel like then you become like
invincible like i feel like
you guys can't be canceled or andrew
schultz and tim dillon these guys can't
none of it can be canceled so i want
that you know like even now i'm doing a
pilot for true tv
and i asked him i was like have you guys
like listened to some i've said wild
[ __ ]
on my podcast like wild nuts [ __ ]
and they were like yeah we listen we
don't kind of don't care and
if the show gets on the air like we'll
deal with it then but even that i'm like
well if you were going to cancel me it
kind of almost helps
in a weird way even though like i don't
want to go through that it it's like oh
because then it
people say like i've only come with
things like from love like if i was
going to make like a racist joke it's
like it's because i'm it's a joke like i
love
people i'm from new york like we love
everybody but this canceled culture [ __ ]
i'm like happy to have a place where
it's like
even if you took it all the way way
protected there my fans would be like no
we're strong we're your base yep
so it will and they will yeah
um i won't do anything to support the
chinese
red white and blue chris no i am on tick
tock yeah
okay good yeah so christina curates uh
talks what she likes to call dark talks
not the ones that they want you to see
not people doing fun dances and making
cupcakes
this is the other real talk the real
tick-tock let's see and we just check
them out every week
hey guys so hey guys i'm sorry about my
hair you know and all that but um
um i did my yoga this morning
and just so you know that's part of my
three
um workouts that you get when you buy
when you buy
my workout plans and it is really great
it stretches me out it gets me motivated
for the day
you should get it guys come on and get
your yoga workout today
that is a good salesperson remember guys
you are worth it you're welcome
you're worth it thank you peace out
thank you third workout of the day man i
like it dude he looks amish yeah he does
and uh first thing i think when i see
him is like this guy knows how to work
out
100 well you want to do your workout ad
laying down on a bed
yeah that really shows people what's the
third workout today
so energized but i'd be more inclined to
support this guy yeah i would support
this guy i'm like yes [ __ ] guy seems
all right you know i'm not i know i'm
not gonna get anything from a workout
class anyway i just like
you either do it or you don't do it i
eat too many black and white cookies
i'll tell you this
later on um i'll just uh i'll let you
know
i i got one of his workouts okay and um
i'll share it with you after okay thank
you i appreciate it i think it's
probably better off the air
yeah yeah i don't want to give away
anything something charges for secrets
can't wait to get ripped he's also got a
sale for military police and
firefighters they get five dollars
as they should yes very very cool i just
wanted to update you guys on his career
thanks a lot for pulling that you got it
yeah
thank you good morning my queen
you are very stunning thank you for the
compliment
and you have a wonderful day you're the
queen of the day
ugh i love that it says we love a
non-pedophilic king
right oh don't forget hello my 18 and
yeah this guy
sometimes makes it clear that he's like
good morning
my 18 plus queens like yeah which is
important in 2020
it is he's you know he's taking full
credit
i like that guy yeah on pedophilia i'm
trying to i think
uh yeah is it here
is this that's the original one there we
go the dark one the dark one good
morning my queen's above
18. yes he makes it real clear
and he rhymes it yeah my queen's above
18.
queen team yeah did you find out by the
way did you find out
uh what was going on here
here's something to think about do you
know when you drink
alcohol oh my god
you're living with the terror right
and after that you're going to be
and they all is this okay okay all right
that's it that's exactly how my dad put
my bangs at the yankee game
that's what i felt like for about a
month after
i i was like looking at them like this
was me when i was 12.
that is the one of the funniest things
that is the distinct heritage
special needs yeah take special nates i
mean these tickets
are like enjoy enjoy the game yeah dude
my dad [ __ ]
so he was like with all like to defund
the police thing
like he like they had one they had a
march in bay ridge
which is like [ __ ] crazy part of
brooklyn like outskirts like
probably like a red you know votes red
area but it was so funny dude like they
tried to [ __ ] do like a little
protest through bay ridge and it just
didn't work there to defund the police
and then the bay ridge guys came out
with signs that said refund the police
they were like refund them give them
more [ __ ] money
i say we pay him double time
yeah my dad it's just funny to just
watch people leave you know
well this whole thing now everything now
is like theatrics though oh sure it's
really for show like i don't know how
many people really
no people are bored as [ __ ] yeah they're
bored out of their minds
i cannot get turned on or stay
interested
if there is no power play or fight for
power either in the streets or in the
sheets
i need both otherwise i'm just gonna get
bored and i'm gonna overpower you
and i'm i know
i need to be bullied as well and i need
you to fight me
don't you love her i just really like
that is she being serious
uh-huh yeah she's like she's a lesbian
on tick tock and she's always putting
these cool like right what i just love
it i just think she's absurd
putting it out there like that but yeah
i mean that this to me
was always like i know she's a lesbian
but like in a straight woman that type
of like
i need to be i need you to [ __ ] with me
psychologically
yeah was always a turn-off what do you
mean
like uh i need to make sure you play
games
if we are together psychotic i thought
when the video started i thought it was
tony hinchcliffe
she could kick tony's ass she probably
could yeah easily oh my god
if you can't handle me in my
pathological need for both
validation and affection you don't
deserve me at my also pathological need
for extremely rough and kinky sex
they're a great match it's too bad she's
gay i love this guy yeah i do too
wow it's a lot these millennials are
just demanding [ __ ] from people
yeah he's one of the most terrifying
guys i think we've ever featured
his arms are so long man i know
shockingly long arms
also the complete total lack of emotion
in his eyes yeah it's a little
off-putting he's dead inside yeah right
he's like
no blinks yeah [ __ ] nuts you might
need like okay
all right well it's an interesting
approach to dating i mean you really
just put it out there those are very
specific needs
the look in the eyes and also to stay
the completely monotone
yeah let's see it again i want to say
and in the shower he's doing it
you can't handle me in my pathological
need for both
validation and affection you don't
deserve me at my also pathological need
for extremely rough and kinky sex
god i know that nose piercing also is
it's real like
right in the middle it's just right
there yeah
i mean you go to the what do you do you
could drill drill it right [ __ ]
and he's like 15 years old what does he
know about
his kinky a guy like this like leaves an
impression
on people like have you ever been in the
presence of like a true sociopath
like a dead inside person i haven't but
my my aunt tells this [ __ ]
the way she told the story to us once
where i was we were like
what so her husband is originally from
utah okay and his sister
when she was like i don't know 16 uh no
not 16 19
in like the 70s goes on a date with this
guy and my answer's like telling a story
goes on a date with this guy and he
she's like you know she's like she's on
the date with this guy she's just like
there's like a sociopathic look
in his eyes like he's dead inside like
he picked her up and it's weird
and she's just like i just feel
extremely uncomfortable like i cannot
explain i'm just
shivering with fear i don't want to be
here anymore on the date because she
would ask him questions and she was like
it wouldn't it would like bounce off him
and he'd give like a programmed response
like robotic
in the 70s and she was like i'm i was
very uncomfortable
with it and so she called her brother my
aunt's husband
to come pick her up and he was like okay
so comes picks her up
they go back no problem the her brother
is going out
the next morning at like 6 30 in the
morning for like his paper route or
something like that the job that he had
and the guy on the date from the night
before runs out of the bushes
so he was waiting at the house to like
do something whatever and it's like so
creepy and weird and like
it just stayed it stayed with this woman
for so long
five years later whatever it was [ __ ]
ted bundy
it was ted bundy she went out on a date
with ted
[ __ ] bundy and to this day never she
said when you're ever in the presence of
a sociopath
you know she was like i've never in a
million years she's like he wasn't doing
anything wrong
he was just looking through me at the
way that i felt so
violently uncomfortable and he was
[ __ ] ted bunny he already killed
women at that time
and like was 100 percent just gonna kill
this lady
which i was like how sick is that and
that when i looked at that guy i just
thought that ted bundy was like that's
like a little
yeah yeah it's like a it's like a gender
fluid ted bundy yeah
he's got dude
when you come in bed and like uh just
cut me up and he'd be like okay
yeah okay yeah problem yeah okay okay
yeah but i mean yeah that's really crazy
man yeah she told that
she was telling us that story and we
were like wow this is like we're on the
edge of our seats we're like crazy and
then she was like
guess who it was yes ted bundy how about
that
yeah she was like ted bundy turkey's
[Laughter]
done
you've just entered black country tick
tock so mind how you go
and keep at the os road this one's a
master of accents can you understand
what the [ __ ] just happened there very
small bits and pieces of it yeah
i i thought he was having a stroke yeah
that's what i thought the tic tac was
oh well that kid you've just entered
black country tick tock so mind how you
do
and keep at the os road mind how you
going keep out the off road
i don't know but you've just entered
black country tick tock yeah
i would not think black country tick
tock would be that guy like it's not
that
it's a much scarier yeah that guy or the
kinky teenager
kinky team all the way kinky teen
running into the kinky teen
outside that house would be the ultimate
thing
hey chrissy hi [ __ ] me
are you ready to push me psychologically
[Laughter]
hey what's up i'm jimmy creek i'm just
looking for a pen pal
or a friend or maybe more if you're
filming the vibe then hit me up at
jp.com
all right peace out here we go i'm from
idaho
originally from california what's up hit
me up currently incarcerated need some
friends
i need some friends there's a friend
this guy needs a patreon
yeah well this is cool so this is a tick
tock prison love and friendship
and you can hook up with inmates dude
and by the way
there's nothing better if you're out
there and you're just looking to connect
with somebody
hit up uh jpeg james creech here james
creed
he's from california so we talk about
cali stuff you can talk about california
stuff yeah
yeah very cool i like this guy yeah the
shirt comes off for this one
here we go oh
oh whoa what's this floyd mayweather's
tick tock
there it is fire
that was really good that was good dude
those are sweet tits i mean
that's a big one i thought the ufc fight
was the best fighting i'd seen in a
while but this
that was pretty good i'm gonna send this
to rogan if you don't mind give me this
uh this file
it's really good do you think roman i
would love to hear his
his comments you know i can send it to
you i'll send it to izzy i'll send it to
israel and be like do you think you can
fight this guy
yeah yeah see what he says see what he
says i just love how he's like take my
shirt off for this one yeah he's really
doing some [ __ ] yeah yeah do you think
like
you could like last like 10 seconds with
like mike tyson
no no no right yeah i know i don't know
that i could even
now he's 53 and uh yeah
here's the thing i mean you could maybe
last 10 seconds
of of not getting hit like right
you could like if you're an athletic
dude but once he
if he's landing about even if you're
blocking and he's landing body shot
hooks it's going to be over real fast
that's the thing with me too is like
people are like oh you're athletic
it's a [ __ ] it's a mirage dude i mean
i played ball but ever since then dude
it's
leading man face best friend body that's
how i roll through these streets
i've i've auditioned for like a marvel
movie they're like take your shirt off
it was like a good audition they're like
put it back on uh i was like yeah it's
just a letdown but now i don't care
is so much great like fighting is insane
with when it comes to athleticism
because athletic people will think like
they can
fight sometimes yeah you're like do you
have a background in fighting and
they're like no you're like
why do you think that you'll just be
able to fight like it's one thing to be
like i fought a dude who said some [ __ ]
to me and yeah
but like against a trained fighter oh
yeah they're gonna [ __ ] destroy you
one of my friends russ
got [ __ ] annihilated this summer in
long beach
new york out into a humongous fist fight
got his [ __ ] ass kicked because he
popped off they were drunk he popped off
on someone and he thought he could
handle himself
because he was take he had taken a month
of cardio kickboxing yeah
it's like cardio kickboxing that [ __ ] my
mom does yeah
you just got your ass handed to you i
was in a boxing gym
where there was like a class and then
there was a
there's a couple rings there so in the
ring
is a there's a 19 year old junior
olympian right oh boy he's just warming
up he's doing he's
he's jumping rope he's working mitts and
then one of the kids
who's been like side by side with us and
we're doing drills
they i you know whatever they're tony uh
like
jump in with him and i'm like you're
gonna jump in with this junior olympian
and i didn't know
that this kid who who was like side by
side doing drills with us in class
was like a prodigy uh he gets in there
and is like
going toe to toe with this with this
junior olympian and i go wait how old is
this this
kid like this right this badass who's
been 15. whoa
he's 15 years old and i and i it was in
that that was the moment where i was
like
this 15 year old without a doubt could
[ __ ] me up beyond recognition a
sophomore in high school could beat the
[ __ ] character
didn't mike tyson start at like 13 years
yeah well he was [ __ ] people
and he would [ __ ] you [ __ ] people up
in the streets yeah and they put them in
yeah they put they started training them
and they were like okay
monster yeah monster one of my friends
when i was 19
years old just decided to get
circumcised this guy he just decided to
get circumstances polish
kid born in poland he was dating this
girl and she's like
she didn't want the foreskin so he got
the [ __ ] cirque and then she dumped
him like two weeks later
but he came into school on crutches
right he comes in on crutches
and he's i'm like dude you hurt your
ankle or something like that he's like
nah it's my back i'm like you shouldn't
be on crutches then he's like no i
should be i'm like what's going on like
tell me the truth what's going on i was
like don't make a big deal but
i got circumcised she wanted to get
circumcised i'm like let me see your
[ __ ] dick right now so
pull he pulls out his dick and i mean
dude it looked like like an isis
beheading video it was like just
i was like holy smokes but we [ __ ]
like two days later you know this idiot
he calls me he's like bro i think i got
an infection in my car
i'm like yeah well you got circle like
why would you get circumcised like we're
19. so anyway we go to the hospital i go
to the hospital because he's like his
dick is just like i mean he had a little
dick and now it's like
really like it's like he's like i can't
even pee like my dick is inside my body
so we go we're waiting in the er and a
guy comes in who had from a boxing gym
the reason i'm bringing up comes in
boxing gym
he had just he was boxing sparring with
someone and allegedly
the story like we were hearing from the
nurses was he thought he was a little
bit better at boxing than he was and
trained with someone who
was professional semi-professional and
they were kind of like digging in on
each other and the
professional hit him with an uppercut
and skimmed his nuts by accident and
split his nut sack open
and his balls fell out of his sack from
about because that [ __ ] guy
thought that he could fight a pro
fighter in you know some
[ __ ] sparring gym i told this story i
told the story um
to joe who then told it who brought it
up if you ever look up
charlie murphy on so funny on rogan
okay so i find out charlie's doing rogan
and i go you got to ask him about johnny
gill
and uh oscar de la hoya he's like what
yeah so what happened was
when i won that i want a contest i met
joe i want a contest
to a stand-up contest to host shows for
him right
john heffron and charlie murphy went on
tour the the maximum bud light real men
of comedy tour was
called and i i'm on the tour and charlie
murphy
asked me if i want to go to dinner with
him and i was like yeah this is like at
the just after
the height of chappelle show stuff and
we're we're at dinner
and johnny goes uh he looks up at the tv
we're at some like restaurant he goes
do you think uh oscar de la hoya could
whoop your ass and i was like
yeah yeah he's like for like for real
right and i was like without a doubt
oscar de la hoya would [ __ ] me up
because he's like that's what i think
too
and i was like what would give you any
doubt about that and he's like
johnny gill and i was like johnny what
did johnny what's johnny gill say yeah
johnny gill the r b saying sure
yeah he goes johnny gill said that he
could whoop oscar de la hoya's ass
i was like what why and he's like
because he's pretty
i was like dude yeah it would happen so
fast you wouldn't even
you wouldn't know dude it didn't start
it it was oscar de la hoya would beat
the [ __ ] out of me
in the lingerie in heels he was wearing
yeah remember
like he would [ __ ] light me up yes
dress like that it's
impossible to beat a professional i
think he's tiny i mean he's
funny professional boxer would kill me
well also it's like with oscar hoya
and anyone like that level it's the
speed that ends up killing you
right like you don't even know that four
punches
have hit you sure like that and you're
you would be like
either on the ground or just completely
disoriented it's so fast so fast
but i love that johnny gill was like i
could kick his ass yeah
johnny no it's so random too
i know and i mean it was it's such a
ridiculous point and i was like
wait johnny gill thinks he could beat up
he's like yeah
you know who i heard is a phenom i did
the show i hope to the show with fat joe
the rapper factor was the [ __ ]
greatest guy of all time yeah but so you
know i haven't seen him in a few years
but when we did the show he told us a
story like
you [ __ ] r kelly is like the baddest
[ __ ]
of all time like we'll beat the [ __ ] out
of anybody
and then like sing you know his songs
like i never knew he was like dude
he was like you know because i said to
him i was like you know being like a
tough rapper i was like who's a guy like
you would never
[ __ ] with he was like you honestly want
my real answer bro mark kelly
i was like mark kelly he was like dude
he's a real [ __ ]
as real as it gets and then i was like
holy [ __ ] balls so i would never think i
remember when
a story first broke about him being a
piece of [ __ ] oh yeah i mean
the first story that broke 10 years ago
oh he went to the same
writer who wrote this expose and he's
still like the guy he's in the
documentaries now
he said that um he's like r kelly is a
filthy man sure he doesn't shower no
like
and he will go like a week and he'll be
just a complete
mess you'll smell him like a [ __ ]
hallway down you'll be like what is that
and it'll be r kelly just like in his
[ __ ]
he's probably has like full-blown mental
illness that's just like he's a mentally
sick guy
yeah you know not that that excuses
anything it's like you just you gotta
just you know
you're saying that you ju you excuse it
and that you love
you're saying no you're saying what
chris is saying yeah chris is saying
that r kelly's actually a good guy yes
you should forgive him for anything that
you think and
with and and i've been watching the
video when he urinated on that girl
because i have the prostatitis and i'm
trying to get motivation to pee because
i can't pee right now because my
prostate's too swollen
so that's the only thing i could do yeah
yeah so i don't know i
i yeah i don't i don't i don't know um
okay
well before we go here i want to just
replug everything history hyenas
with you and janice papa's yes you have
a patreon patreon.com
bay ridge boys and on the what is it
16th uh
you're october 23rd sorry october 23rd
at chrisdcomedy.com livestream show
anywhere in the country you can buy
tickets right now anywhere in the world
and then october 8th to the 11th i'm on
tour with andrew santino
oh the steamy windows tour that's right
you guys are doing driving drive-ins
cape cod massachusetts which i believe
is sold out and then uh butler
pennsylvania scranton pennsylvania and
delaware
nice this was absolutely fantastic thank
you thank you so much
i appreciate you guys this was a lot of
fun thank you our closing song cool
girls club and this is rare
it's by uh versace kolachi a a female a
lady
versace uh cool girls club and she also
has a cameo
by the desperate one my blue haired uh
summer girlfriend from episode one of
the live show
oh wow okay yes very nice thank you here
we go
[Music]
for sachi kalachi speaking uh who the
[ __ ] is this
it's me purple hair girl from the chair
i was the one
myself on cam that time remember oh hell
yeah man what ups this i remember you
you were flicking your bean on the couch
i remember you what i don't have time to
talk listen where are you
at um i'm just home here now hold up
though where are you calling
from i'm stuck way down in the mountains
i need you to come get me
yeah i can do that i'm looking at
say eight o'clock 8 15. [ __ ] you're
doing good
thank you so much you're literally
saving my life
bam say no more i am on the way [ __ ]
awesome piss on me beat me you're the
coolest for this
no you are you are the coolest cool
girls for life
weep out of here marcel went down into
the mountain we're rolling anderson
cooper took my sister and now we gotta
expose him if you're a hufflepuff do not
piss me off just keep on scrolling i
ain't impressed by crown molding show me
that dick that you holding
to tell i'm a [ __ ] walking mermaid
[ __ ] i dip my nuggets in the doo doo
guess what
loving it i drink moose soup 100 leaves
specifically
delicious story time uh how you saying
i'm not a racist
i like remember the
that's what we do you do you do do not
do you and yes my eyes are tattooed
funny story
ex perry is in jail do you ever worry
that you're our word and no one's
telling you
i'm reckless eyeballing hope such as i
was made up
selling a necklace made of moose turds
out the back of my trunk
all right [ __ ] listen up you'll
never make potter [ __ ]
if you ain't licking the scrum honey you
ain't tricking no worries
when i see a spartan kicker
[Music]
hardcore enough
energetic template a spirit working star
c channeler hybrid astral key hurry up
before i take your bike
you better not touch me [ __ ]
[ __ ] you need to restock the
hot cocoa when you're done with it
some caffeine take a hammock [ __ ] pop
the vasectomy stitch
now i'm straight pulling by with vocal
fry and size g tip i keep smelling my
vagina and hopes that it'll smell better
it just doesn't show the haters how you
glass and put your perfect smile lit
i'm ride or die show me the body mommy
we'll chop it up together dip that [ __ ]
in ass and watch it decay in a row with
weather
why did it change up the evidence we got
the word clever bye bye bye
[Music]
put it in your mouth and lick
[ __ ] my stoma don't free no chomosa
chomas though i'm blowing cincinnati
parts at every goddamn place that'll go
i'm not a whole
player follow that bro i'm gonna make
you wanna shadow [ __ ] my [ __ ] two big
day songs by toe down we bout to get
smoking and drinking and rocking adidas
[Music]
this is the cool girls club within the
house of your mother
i was over mama's last night just
visited as cheryl jumped over the
kitchen counter at me flying like whose
own boat in a fighting suit i don't know
why the [ __ ] always be jealous of me
so
she run to the phone like the [ __ ] made
gun always does and i said you better
call every law in sequoyah county this
time [ __ ] cause you're gonna need help
pricing my fingers from around your
[ __ ] dick sucking thought so i ended
up arrested in jail but i'm out this
morning sheryl and i could still see
that's right you didn't swallow [ __ ]
[ __ ] and i'm coming over here today and
i'm going to do the two step
in the cowboy boogie till there's a mud
hole in your [ __ ] ass
hi mommy thanks jeans thank you for
watching this episode of your mom's
house and if you had a great time
watch more videos here here here don't
forget to subscribe here here here so
that
you will know when your mom's house
video comes out immediately
thanks jeans